Are we ready?
Can we?
Yeah, I'm going to do the consent.
I don't need to reconvene us.
So, good morning everyone.
You can see that we are beginning to practice social distancing.
All of the chairs are further apart from each other.
We're going to be bringing people in in smaller numbers.
If you're keeping up with the news, there's, you know, advancing
understanding of and knowledge about the spread of the coronavirus, and we want you to care for each other by not hugging, practice the California elbow bump, and stay safe and as far apart as you comfortably can.
So, we will see some adjustments to our meeting for the day.
But we're going to move right ahead now with our consent agenda, which is the regular consent items 10 through 13, and start by asking if there are any public comments on items 10 through 13.
I think we're going out to find if there are public comments.
Things have been a little hectic this morning, so.
We'll know in a moment.
Hang on one minute.
We will get to your comment.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Bill Schultz, Joe Hendricks, Hector Perez-Ponches, Juan Gallegos, and Eric Premack.
And please leave about six feet between you.
This is for the consent items.
Are these?
This is items, consent items 10 through 13.
Welcome.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Good morning and thank you State Board President Darlene Hammond and board members.
My name is Bill Schutz speaking on item 13.
I'm with Danis Pelliver-Kelly here on behalf of Yuba City Unified School District to voice our objection to the issuance of a charter school number for Pathways Charter Academy.
We submitted a letter to the board yesterday outlining the details why the pathways number 2089 should be removed from that list identified for assignment of a charter school number.
The state board holds the important role of gatekeeper to ensure that a charter school number which opens the path to issuance of a CDUS code and entitlement to public funding is only issued to a charter school that is formed in compliance with the law.
Among other things, Pathways violates the current moratorium for new classroom-based charter schools.
The moratorium applies to Pathways even though its petition was approved prior to January 1st because it doesn't fall within the narrow exception to section 47612.7.
This interpretation is consistent with other provisions of AB 1505 which apply to changes to charter schools depending on whether they were in operation as of October 1st.
Also, the October 30th memo from state superintendent Thurman to the board and consistent with the legislative purpose for the moratorium.
With that, we request the state board exercises authority and remove pathways from the list before you today.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Joe Hendricks, Deputy Superintendent for the Sutter County Office of Education.
I'm here to speak regarding the Pathways Charter Academy numbering package on the board agenda today.
AB 1505 moratorium does not impact non-classroom based charter schools approved prior to January 1, 2020.
AB 1505 created a two-year moratorium on the approval of non-classroom based charter school petitions.
The new law was not effective until January 1st and its limits did not go into effect until that date.
Although AB 1505 provides two narrow exceptions to the moratorium, those are only exceptions and not the rule.
Pathways Charter Academy petition was approved on December 13, 2019.
Therefore,
It was timely and properly approved before the moratorium went into effect.
I respectfully request the board approve the charter numbering package for Pathways Charter Academy.
Thank you.
Are there any other public comment?
Can we ask staff to speak to the point that was just made by these two speakers?
With regards to the Judy size chief counsel with regards to the moratorium It is our interpretation that the moratorium does not take effect until January 1 and there is so this petition was approved prior to January 1 and therefore it is Proper proper and legit, okay If there is any other further discussion
Do I have a motion?
A consent calendar.
Thank you.
A second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Agenda item 14 is a public hearing regarding the petition for renewal of a charter school under the oversight.
I did see, however, that Lisa Costanza was here.
Are you in a position to want to make an announcement yet, Lisa?
Okay, why don't you do that before we do the petition for the charter school because that may be a long item.
I know that many people are
trying to keep track of the executive orders and the work of the department in terms of helping schools make their way through decisions about closing and service of students given the coronavirus events.
So Lisa Costanzo is here to give us some updates on that and then we may get a further announcement later in the day because there's a lot in motion.
Correct.
Thank you.
So I would say that that's probably an understatement.
Everything is continuing to go hour by hour.
I will start by just saying that we have been involved in daily calls with the governor's office and his task force really around the Corona COVID-19.
So we're involved in daily calls.
We are continually working with the California Department of Public Health, the California Health and Human Services Agency on what kind of guidance we can provide.
So just over the weekend, we were involved with
actually helping them put together the school guidance that was released on Saturday evening to all the schools.
We put it out through our listservs to superintendents, charter school administrators, and county supes as well.
On top of that, we have been continuing to work and we also participated in an exercise that the governor's office did last Friday as well as this kind of continues to evolve.
Currently, the most recent guidance, part of the school guidance that came out on Sunday, there was also a guidance for higher ed that came out and also a guidance around large gatherings.
So just as recently as last night, there was a guidance that came out at about 11 p.m.
around state public health
experts announcing that gatherings with 250 people or more should be rescheduled or canceled.
So that is the most updated guidance.
It also says that if they are non-essential, they should be limited to no more than 250 people.
And if you are going to have them to exercise social distance, which has become our new term here, along with making sure we're not shaking hands and
continuing to talk about everyone washing their hands for 20 seconds.
So as you can tell, this morning, our staff kind of jumped in and did as best we could to adhere to some of the guidance that came out last night.
So we are continuing to work on this as it evolves.
We are already hearing this morning that, you know, school districts are having emergency meetings about what this means for them.
So we're waiting to see what happens here in the next few hours.
Stephanie and I have already been engaged in some of this this morning.
At this point, as I mentioned, it's continuing to evolve.
The governor's office has been reaching out to us multiple times on a daily basis to see how best we can partner in these conversations.
We're having some today about distance learning, about independent study and what that looks like.
So it's continuing to evolve.
is what I can say at this point.
And the latest guidance is what I just mentioned that came out last night at 11 o'clock.
Are there any specific questions that I can try and answer?
Of course, on the school closures and distance learning, right?
Yes.
And we would just add that it's really important that our schools work very closely with their county public health offices, that any decision that they're thinking about, that they collaborate with their county public health office to make the right decision for their area.
That has been the continual message and it resides through the school guidance document.
It's the continual message that the locals please continue to work through their county public health departments to make those determinations on school closures and how they proceed, how they move forward.
So that has been a continual message from us and from the governor's office on how we should be proceeding.
And also including their county office of education as well in their decision because that county office will have a kind of a landscape of what's happening around that county with districts.
No problem.
There will be more today we're working on.
We'll call you up later for more.
I will keep a tab on things and let you know if anything evolves throughout the day.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Now we'll go to agenda item 14 which is a public hearing regarding
The petition for the renewal of a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education.
Consideration of Academia Advance Charter which was denied by the Los Angeles Unified School District.
Member Ortiz-Lacon must recuse prior to opening this item and looks like she's already done that.
The CDE proposes to recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing to deny the request to renew AAC, a grade six through 12 charter school, based on the department's findings pursuant to EC section 47605 and California Code of Regulations, title five, section 11967.5.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Gregson, and the board.
I'm Stephanie Farland, the Director of the Charter Schools Division, and as
As President Darling-Hammond mentioned, we're here today to talk about, for this public hearing, Academia Advance.
Academia Advance Charter is an SB authorized charter school, which was with the term expiring June 30th, 2020.
Oops, I got to remember to do this too.
As required by law, they did submit to their local school district before coming up to the board.
They submitted to LA Unified School District on August 19, 2019, and the LAUSD board denied the petition by a vote of 6 to 1.
On December 2nd, they submitted their petition to the State Board of Ed.
This was heard at the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools at our February 5th, 2020 meeting.
The ACCS moved the CDEU staff recommendation to deny the petition on a vote of 6 to 3.
As mentioned earlier, we are recommending that the SBE deny the request to renew Academia Vonce, which is a grade 6 through grade 12 charter school.
The basis for that recommendation is that they are not consistent with sound educational practice, does not perform overall or at least equal to its comparable school districts,
whether students would otherwise attend, and they're demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program based on fiscal concerns, declining enrollment, and the sound educational practice.
So in terms of reasonably comprehensive description, there are several elements within the charter petition itself that were not satisfactory.
We'll talk a little bit more about that later, but there were issues in the governance structure, employee qualifications, and dispute resolution procedure.
So if approved,
today and as a condition of approval, we would recommend that they change some things in their petition in order to be recommended and to move forward.
They have been in operation since September 2005, so it's not it's not their first renewal.
They were originally authorized by LAUSD in 2005.
They were denied by LAUSD on renewal.
Then they were approved by the county, LA County Office Board.
on the appeal of that renewal.
So they were approved by the LA board in May 2010.
And then when they came up for renewal, they were again denied renewal in 2015.
And in that instance, they came to the state board and were approved.
They are proposing to serve 350 students in grade 6 through grade 12 on two leased facility sites.
They are, as a little background, are a college preparatory school.
Their goal is to ensure that all pupils complete the A to G requirements and are equipped to be accepted into colleges and universities and have opportunities to develop into active citizens characterized by the ideals of a diverse and democratic society.
So we'll get into our findings now.
The CDE selected eight schools, four middle and four high schools, where pupils would otherwise attend and that are comparable and that they have similar enrollment for similar significant subgroups.
And this is a little bit of a change.
We initially, before the ACCS meeting, had selected four schools for
for comparable schools and after the ACCS meeting, after hearing some of the testimony, after listening to Yvonne say, we expanded that to eight schools.
Yvonne say had more schools in their comparable, had selected more schools to compare and felt that some of the schools that we had initially
selected had magnet programs within their school, although those magnet programs didn't have program requirements, academic program requirements, they felt that that wasn't a fair selection of schools.
So, for this round, we added four additional schools and we took those schools off of Avance's list that they had used before ACCS.
So, we did listen during ACCS and changed some of our comparable school selections.
Having done that, it did not change our recommendation.
They still are not performing as well as many of the area schools that kids would otherwise attend in LA Unified.
We also determined in looking at the data that they are underserving their EL population, and we'll get into some of that in a minute.
As far as the dashboard is concerned, there's a lot of words on that, but they do have colors for everything, and I'll go on to the next slide so you can see, and it should be in your packet, the colors.
In terms of English language arts, they are an orange in terms of, this is 2018, so we can compare 2018 to 2019.
They were orange in ELA,
and orange in math.
They had high chronic absenteeism, as you can see there, and they were red in 2018, and their suspension rate was at orange, high college to career in blue.
Move on to the next year, which is dashboard for the year 2019.
They improved in their absenteeism.
They improved in their suspension rate.
They went down in their college and career, went up one in their English language arts, and went down in mathematics, which is currently a red.
And that's a red for all groups and subgroups.
And here's, I really like these little slides because it gives you a good sense of how far away they are from standard in English language arts and in math.
And you can see that they have made improvements in their English language arts over the course of the last three school years.
Oops, I'm going backwards.
Mathematics, unfortunately, has gone the other way.
They did have a small bump in 2017-18, and then they went back down again in 2018-19.
And you can see there how many points they are below standard.
With English learner progress, they are, and we were gonna have some data people here, so I'm pretty sure I'm right about this, is that ELs do not have a color yet in terms of that.
But we can see what their results are in terms of English language acquisition.
and we do have them, we can look at their performance level, which is very low, which is the lowest that you can get, and that they actually have decreased this past year in their LP levels for English language learners.
The board does and the staff does review alternative measures pursuant to Ed Code 52052F.
And as I kind of went over a little bit, the data from the AAC alternative measures reflect some increases in their ALPAC results and their graduation rate, college going rate, and there was a decline in their suspension rate.
A lot of the alternative measures, though, that they send in can't be verified by us.
They're not through, we don't use them in our own accountability system, so while I'm sure Avance, when they come up, will be presenting information from some of their alternative measures, like NWEA,
We have no way of verifying that, and so we sort of make that statement in terms of not being able to verify some of the alternative measures that they use if they're not within our state system.
But there are a couple of areas that are, that we can look at and that we can verify, and we did look at their advanced placement test scores and their SAT scores.
I think it was important for us to understand because, and they'll come up and let you know this, they do have a high college going rate.
So a large, higher than most schools in LA Unified School District.
And so there was a little disconnect for us when we were digging into the data.
Because on the assessments that students normally are required to take in order to get into college, AP is not one of those, but SAT is.
But the AP is a good sign of, you know, they are offering ADG classes there and where the kids are placing on those AP exams.
We were able to look at some of the data there.
And again, hopefully you can see it on your screens.
I know that's a lot of numbers on the screen.
But they were far below LAUSD in their AP exam outcomes in terms of, if you're familiar with the AP exam, you generally, three, four, five are passing scores.
universities generally look at four and fives, and they had in the last round that we were able to pull off the data system, they had two percent of their kids scored at a four, two percent at three, and the rest, which was close to 95 percent, scored at a one and a two.
So that was
That was interesting to learn because they do have a high college going rate.
Same with the SAT scores.
About 80, let's see, 34, 54%
Well, 34% met standards for reading and writing.
19% met standards for mathematics.
And again, well below LAEOC's average.
And just another disconnect in the terms of their high college going rates and not having the scores to reflect that.
Obviously, Academia Avance did their own charter review.
Before I go there, I do want to make a statement.
If you saw the ACCS, we had written in the ACCS item that they were eligible for differentiated assistance.
And after the ACCS meeting, our analysis measurement and accountability division reviewed the business rules associated with the creation of the charter school differentiated assistance file.
And as a result of that review, Avanse and several other charter schools came off the list.
So they are no longer on the list for differentiated assistance.
If you have more questions about how that worked, why that worked, why we had to change the business rules, I'm sure that somebody here from our AMR division can answer those questions.
So Academia Avante did their own review.
They did their own data comparison.
They showed some of their improvements that we talked about earlier from ELA and math.
They will spend some time talking to you about their review.
LA Unified also did a review.
their data supported a finding that their performance of academia avance is not at least equal to the LAUSD schools that the students would otherwise attend.
LAUSD was going to be here today, and they have stopped and postponed travel for their staff.
So, unfortunately, LAUSD will not be here.
Oh, yeah, so their GR person is here, but we were expecting their programmatic charter folks and their fiscal folks to be here today.
And they told us last night that they were not able to come.
So that is, you know, it's unfortunate that they won't be able to be here to support their findings.
After the ACCS meeting, Academia Advance did send in a different set of data accessed through the LAUSD open data portal.
We couldn't really verify the data because when we looked at the numbers, we have access, we could look into the portal, but we didn't, we couldn't verify the data because the numbers that they used in their chart didn't seem to add up correctly for us.
And we can talk about that too if you'd like.
So we just could not verify whether their data was correct.
They also sent in an academic plan that was just sent last week, I think.
So, ACCS nor LAUSD had the opportunity to review that plan.
And it is a academic plan in what they're doing currently in the school year and what they'll be doing in the next couple of years to bring up their achievement levels by their students.
The second piece of our denial recommendation has to do with the inability to implement.
So AAC has a history of recurring audit findings and deficit spending.
There's ongoing concerns based upon CDE's review of their independent audit reports for the last few years.
They did significantly decline in their ending fund balance, and they can talk a little bit about that in terms of due to their losses from a divestiture in an LLC that they were invested in.
I'd say the bigger issue
for CDE is that AAC has a history of selling receivables in order to pay its financial obligations.
Are we all familiar with selling receivables, or would you like me to talk a little bit about that?
I'm not a fiscal person, but I do understand the concept of selling receivables.
Oftentimes, the majority of funding that flows to charters are on a fixed schedule.
And that doesn't always align with when the charter needs cash to pay bills.
And so if a charter is in need to borrow money, they often go to a lender.
And that lender will provide them cash today for a fee.
And in exchange, the charter assigns its future state payments to the lender.
So it's like a loan with high interest rates.
They've been doing this for a long time.
and are projecting that they will continue to use this as a fiscal tool for the next few years.
It's a huge issue for us.
The only way that, so if we go to the next page, I'm going to go to the next page and then I'm going to go back.
You see it might sound weird that we're saying that their project projected budget is viable.
It is viable as long as they're using receivables.
If they were not, then we would have a different story.
So you can see there and the.
previous slide, how much AAC has paid in fees to the charter school capital, which is one of these pretty well-known lending firms.
It's quite a bit in terms of what they've paid up through 2018-19, and then what they're not paying anything this year, but then next year, 2021, you see what the estimates are for future payment, and that's just in their fees for money that they will have to borrow.
in order to have the kind of cash they need to pay their bills.
So while we say that their projected budget is viable, take that as a caveat that they have to sell receivables to do that.
Also, in terms of their enrollment, they never really made as much progress as they wanted to in their projected enrollment.
The slide tells you this is the projected enrollment that they had when they were approved by this board in 2015.
At this point, they projected they would have 625 students.
They currently have about 350.
in grades six through 12.
And so we are concerned, I think that area in general, and if LAUSD was here, but I think they said it at ACCS, a lot of the schools are in declining enrollment in that area.
So we are concerned also about their enrollment.
The CDE finds that the AEC petition, as I had mentioned earlier, does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of the following required elements, the governance structure, employee qualifications, and dispute resolution procedures.
And all of those are in your A1 in much more detail.
So the summary is we are recommending denial of the petition.
We feel that they are inconsistent with sound educational practice, does not perform overall at least equal to its comparable district schools, that they're unlikely to successfully implement the intended program because of fiscal concerns and declining enrollment, and they did not give a reasonably comprehensive description of all the required elements.
And so that's it.
So I think we will hear from the school.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Sure, that's fine.
A couple of clarifying questions.
We're going to come back up before I open the public hearing.
So, Stephanie, on, at least it's on page nine of the handout, but, I'm sorry, it's on page nine of the handout.
It's, I think, slide 18, where you've got the alternative measures, the AP test scores, and then the next one is on the SAT test scores.
Just to clarify, neither of these were presented at ACCS, right?
No.
Okay.
And also, I'm curious about why you chose to compare to the entire district as opposed to the comparison schools.
I think because when we looked at Avance's second round of data that came in later, they were doing that.
And I don't have, I really don't have a better answer than that.
We didn't take a look at all of the schools.
We just wanted to report, yeah, so I'm sorry Sue.
Okay, so I just would say that if we're going to use a comparison set of schools, which I think is appropriate because they're serving a very specific kind of population, that we follow that through with all of the data that we're presenting would be my request.
Then the last clarifying question or just comment is on slide number 23, which talks about the past fiscal concerns, the last point you make there about significant decline in ending fund balance due to this divestiture,
My understanding was that we required them to do that divestiture when we approved the renewal the last time.
I would have to ask Okay, yeah, so I just think just so for you know in the interest of full disclosure It's not it we kind of put them in that bond so just to clarify.
Thank you.
Thank you
Questions, I'm gonna open the public hearing then I hereby open the public hearing at 913 912 a.m.
First we'll hear from the petitioners the petitioners will have 10 minutes then we will hear from the district that is opposing the renewal petition and
They will also have a total of 10 minutes.
After the presentations from both sides, there will be an opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each.
I understand that in the interest of safety, the school has brought some video presentations and will read some public comment, which we appreciate them.
organizing for us in the cause of social distancing that we're engaged in today.
So, Patricia is available to present.
I'll just note a couple of folks have reasons that they have to take calls this morning.
So, member Nava will step out in the middle of this presentation at some point because of a planned call.
Karen Staffold just had to do the same.
People are keeping a lot of business balls in the air today.
All right.
Good morning State Board.
Thank you very much and we did have several
So yes, Ricardo Mireles with Academia Avance.
We had several parents and students that were not able to come.
So let me move through our presentation.
And you have that in front of you, I believe.
There's a printed copy that you're seeing.
This is the population that we're serving.
It is the highest need population for our region in terms of socioeconomic status.
Important here is that the only significant subgroup that has different data is the English learners because
the Latino population is essentially school-wide and the socioeconomic status is essentially school-wide.
These are the references that we use for our program.
I think you guys are familiar with this.
It's part of our Alliance House program and our Life Prep program.
The intention is to try to close the savvy gap.
Oh yes, it's up there.
Here is information about our high school completers amongst the schools in our region that we were compared to.
We have the highest graduation rate and the lowest dropout rate.
And our key signature here is the fact that we are among the top schools for sending students to college.
And in particular for high population of socioeconomically disadvantaged, we're the top three schools in all of LA Unified.
college attainment and here the look is in terms of persistence.
70% of our alumni are in a four-year program or have already completed their four-year program and this is a specific look in terms of statewide trends.
We are doing double of what the statewide is for Latino students and where our students are continuing on to a post-secondary institution.
I also want to point out that
we're high in terms of having our students go to four-year programs as opposed to two-year programs.
This is the NWA data, lots to see in here but let me move kind of quickly.
What you see is four different subjects and for four different years and then all the grades and the trend is
a big gap to the brown line, which is the national norm, but us consistently moving up so that we finally match the national norm.
And even though it's data that other schools aren't using, we reference the fact that it is nationally normed and recognized information.
This is the key piece that we wanted to bring to your attention today and it goes to the issue of the open data dashboard.
If you do a fair comparison by having proper grade spans so 11th graders compared to 11th graders and middle schools compared to middle school and if you take out the magnet school data which is available through the open data dashboard
We only learned of that recently.
Then in these comparisons to the list of schools that was provided by the state for this last round of comparisons, 59% of the time were better than the high schools and 69% of the time were better than the middle schools.
So it's important because the law states the schools that the students would otherwise attend, it's not clear that they would be able to attend the magnet school programs.
Speaking to recruitment, we really took this issue and we have now enrollment commitments for next fall that surpass 450.
We have some binders here.
that if people want to actually verify or look through these commitments, but it puts us at plus 100 over the 350 target that we have for the fall.
And we have someone who will speak to this recruitment effort.
The fiscal health, we have our fiscal person that will address these questions that were brought up.
But we believe we do have the issue is as was brought up by board member Burr that the challenge that we had for those years is to meet the condition that was given to us.
We actually see that now we have we're meeting the reserve requirements and we have the projections that will let us continue forward.
We meet the renewal criteria and we'll have someone from our staff also, but we want to remind you that this should be a de novo review.
And then if you couldn't verify our data, then did you verify the L-Unified data?
And I think that's an issue that needs to be equally, that tests need to be applied on both sides.
Specifically, given that they are now acknowledging, Dr. Perry has acknowledged that they did include the magnet school outcomes in their comparisons, which makes it problematic.
We have Mr. Frankfurt now who will speak quickly about our academic plan and then we're going to complete our presentation and have some speakers.
I'm here to address our academic plan for this and future school years and also address a number of the concerns that were brought up in the earlier presentation.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm Josh Frankfurt.
I'm the instructional coordinator for Academia Advance.
We're focused on three goals.
One, 7% growth on CASP.
Two, greater math aptitude measured by 7% growth on CASP.
And three, 15% growth in EL reclassification.
These are not new concerns acknowledged at the midnight hour of this renewal process.
These have been identified since summer, and programs have been put in place with guidance from CDE on implementation during the fall semester.
I'd like to walk you through our plan, and I'm happy to answer any questions.
Beginning this fall, after being piloted in individual classrooms for three years, Success for All strategies were rolled out in every classroom.
Each teacher is observed weekly and coached bi-weekly for best practices, data analysis, and rigor.
We're developing integration of resources through the LA Library, including a library card, access to online tutoring, access to 215 databases, and more.
We're also supporting students' emotional needs with Kickboard to encourage positive choices.
Math aptitude is, we acknowledge, our greatest challenge.
Students arrive well below grade level and require rapid recovery.
In response, Avance purchased IXL.
A high school readiness math review is also being piloted.
Finally, our reclassification rate has underperformed.
SFA and parallel teaching offer individual assistance for EL students.
We purchased ListenWise to improve listening skills.
We have adopted a profile system, tracking progress and informing next steps.
Parents receive monthly progress reports with action steps.
We have also followed LAOSD's example, revising our reclassification policy for SPED.
Finally, we are looking into the creation of an ELD-specific course for next year.
We monitor data and feedback to determine each program's impact.
Thus far, we're on track to meet our goals.
Students have answered 213,099 questions.
3,029 skills have been completed to proficiency, and 1,817 skills have been mastered on IXL.
The average diagnostic is set to grow 1.8 grade levels in one year.
In both ELA and math,
This year's mean scale score is the highest we have ever had for winter map.
Average fall to winter growth is also our greatest ever.
And for the first time, both 8th and 11th grades, oh, thank you, both 8th and 11th grades are performing above the national norm for reading.
Using our EL profiles, we've already moved one student.
We have another eight profile E's which need only the LPAC.
An additional seven scored three on last year's LPAC and need extra attention to push to a four.
These students are partaking in weekly tutoring sessions to prepare.
Our SPED team has identified two students who are candidates for reclassification under the new guidelines.
In total, 17 students are within striking distance of reclassification and one has qualified, representing 29% of our EL population with a path to reclassification.
There is work to be done.
We are committed to doing it.
We have been doing it.
We hope that our test results being equal to non-magnet schools, our graduation and college going rates, the nearly actually 475 students that have signed up interest forms that are interested in joining us, and the impact of our program will allow us to continue serving our kids, our families, and our community.
Thank you very much.
As we complete our time here, let me state that we have a statement from our special ed person who actually fell ill last night and is submitting it via video.
We also have an extensive mental wellness counseling program that she'll speak to.
On the issue of the English learners, there's kind of a catch-22 here in that if you really push hard for reclassification as we did two years ago, and we had 45% who recognized it, then it leaves the folks that have the biggest need and they're obviously going to score low, right?
So I hope you recognize that.
We also had a big entry from a significant number of unaccompanied minors.
And so these are students that are not coming in in the sixth or seventh grade, they're coming in in the 10th and 11th grade with significant higher needs.
Lastly, other clarifying points on the issue of advanced placement or SAT scores, our focus is on getting the students to complete the AG requirements, right?
And we are successful at that and obviously it's working because they're going to college.
But and we have our goal is not 100% to take the SAT test, right?
If we're compared to other measures often the schools are only testing half the students and so that that measure is off.
So there are some careful points to look at in terms of the data.
We appreciate the opportunity to present here.
We have some speakers that can speak more to some of the specifics here and I look forward to be able to answer your questions.
Thank you very much.
Linda, because um, Ricard mentioned that there you had video, were you going to do that as part of the public hearing or from your staff?
Okay, I think now we're going to hear from LAUSD.
Great.
Should I go?
Okay, thank you.
Good morning President Darlene Hammond, board members and staff.
My name is Marta Alvarez and I'm the Director of Government Relations for the Los Angeles Unified School District.
Before I begin, I would like to point out that as a result of the coronavirus situation that we're closely monitoring, my colleagues from the Charter School Division were not able to be here today to answer questions.
As such, I will be providing prepared remarks on behalf of Los Angeles Unified and I will not be able to answer questions since I am not the subject matter expert on charter schools or on this petition.
Los Angeles Unified supports the Department of Education staff recommendation for the State Board of Education to deny renewal for the Academic Advancement Charter or AAC.
I would like to focus my comments on two areas.
First, the academic renewal criteria findings.
As noted in CDE's report, the CDE reviewed the information provided by LA Unified and has determined that LA Unified's review and analysis of the people achievement data pursuant to education code section 47607 was comprehensive
and supports the finding that AAC performance is not as equal to the LA Unified Schools that AAC pupils would otherwise attend.
CDE's evaluation did not wholly rely on LA Unified's findings.
CDE conducted its own analysis of the data and selected eight comparison middle schools and high schools where pupils would otherwise attend and that are comparable in that they have similar enrollment for similar significant subgroups.
CDE concluded that AAC does not perform at least equal to or greater than the CDE chosen comparable schools.
Four of these schools are not on our list of comparison schools which demonstrate CDE independently did their own data analysis including selecting what they deem are comparison schools.
Since it was brought up about magnet schools, we did include that information, magnet students, into our performance data.
However, our findings are still relevant considering the fiscal findings and other considerations we took into account.
Secondly, we support CDE's findings that the AAC petition does not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of three of the required elements and is not able to successfully implement the intended program.
Finally, I would like to address the fiscal issues.
Based on the CDE report on August 1st, 2019,
AAC has a fair financial standing, which means that a charter school has shown signs of fiscal distress and needs to take appropriate action to address the declining financial condition.
AAC's four-year history of selling receivables to pay for financial obligations, history of falling below recommended 5 percent cash reserves, and history of recurring audit findings remains a concern, and AAC has not improved significantly in order to negate LA Unified's findings from October 2019.
In conclusion, Los Angeles Unified supports the Department of Education's recommendation and stand by the findings of fact that were adopted by the LA Unified School Board on October 15, 2019.
Thank you.
I think at this point we're ready for public comment and we are going to take public comment at one minute per person.
I know there's some arrangements for the showing of the video that will replace some of the public comment that we would have otherwise had.
Yes, I'm going to call five speakers at a time again.
We ask speakers to space yourself appropriately with the six-foot rule and The first five speakers at Michael Yuba.
We have a statement from Assemblyman Creole Margot Gomez Janelle Riley and Spencer styles and
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Michael Jubin.
I represent the California Teachers Association.
CTA recommends that the State Board of Education deny the renewal petition of the AAC as recommended by the CDE.
And we oppose this renewal for the following reasons.
First, AAC significantly underperforms in multiple areas as compared to their CDE chosen comparable schools.
There was significant fiscal concerns given past audit findings, deficit spending, CDE concerns with their ability to pay its future obligations, and a history of declining enrollment at AAC and in the surrounding areas.
The Los Angeles Unified School District, which has spoke, and the ACCS were both correct to deny the renewal petition, and the State Board of Education should deny this renewal petition as well.
Thank you.
At the request of Assemblymember Wendy Carrillo, I'm going to read the statement.
So, good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darning-Hammond, members of the State Board of Education.
Thank you for allowing me this opportunity to speak in support of Academia Vance.
I strongly encourage you to renew their charter.
Academia Vance is in my district, 51.
which I have the honor of representing.
I have visited the school and Avance students and parents have visited my office on multiple occasions.
Avance has had a positive impact on the students and families it serves.
Avance offers first generation students just like me, the assembly member, an opportunity to succeed.
I feel safe, nurtured, and supported.
Having grown up in the district I now represent, I have graduated from public schools impacted by large classroom sizes, limited resources, and at time a school calendar on a track system.
I understand firsthand the educational challenges and barriers students in my community are facing and how hard their parents are working to achieve education equity.
Many of the students that I want to come from mixed status families who fear unjust deportations as well as unjust evictions in a community facing gentrification and displacement.
My request is that you don't take away what is perhaps the one stable thing in their young lives and that is their school, their teachers, their classmates and the safety of their classrooms.
I believe there is a strong case for renewal when all factors are taken into consideration and ask that you please renew the Avance Charter.
Thank you for your time.
That's a statement from Assemblymember Wendy Carrillo.
Good morning, State Board members, President Linda Darling-Hammond.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Many, and Core here today in support of Academia Avance's Charter for Renewal.
LA Unified has acknowledged to the charter school that its comparison data was in, sorry, that the schools that it compared to were incorrect insofar as it compared Academia Advance's data to some magnet school, magnet programs.
What the law says in terms of comparison is that we have two different groups of schools that we're comparing to, schools that students are otherwise required to attend and also schools in the district that are demographically comparable.
Students could not be required to attend a magnet school by definition.
These are selective admission programs.
And again, students can't be required.
They have to apply to attend.
LA Unified, in addition to that, also discounted alternative measures.
They said just flat out, we're not going to consider these alternative measures.
So if their comparison is inaccurate and they didn't use alternative measures, there's nothing then for the district's recommendation for denial to stand on.
Thank you very much.
We urge your de novo review.
Good morning.
Thank you for the opportunity to be here.
My name is Margaret Godinez.
I serve on the board for Academia Advance.
And I'm here asking for support of charter renewal.
I wanted to address one of the questions that came up regarding cash balance.
I just met with the board and I wanted to bring you up to date.
As of 6-30, 2020 cash balance is projected to be $376,000 above the 4% required for a reserve, which is $202,000.
Also want you to know that we do forecast not relying so much on receivable sales.
There has been a tremendous effort on behalf of the board to work on improving financial status.
But I also want to mention something that was just brought up by the last speaker.
This school is a very successful school.
I also am a representative of the Highland Park area.
I grew up in that neighborhood.
And it has all the factors of the school.
The focus is on the kids.
You'll be affecting 350 families.
Thank you.
I'm going to go ahead and call the next six speakers.
And following these speakers, there will be a video.
Hector Perez Pacheco, Eric Premack, Manuel Garu,
Esmeralda Balavendo, Milagros Valencio, Jose Chicada, and then we have video after that.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Spencer Stiles, president and CEO of Charter Impact.
We serve as the school's business management firm.
So a couple of things I just wanted to point out.
In summary, I think it's important to take into account the school's most recent audit shows that any and all prior audit findings or deficiencies have been corrected and none are outstanding at this point.
And they have met and are meeting the fund balance reserve requirements.
When it comes to receivable sales, again, I don't think anybody in this room would enjoy the idea of spending additional school funds on interest costs, but it is a very commonly used practice as well as required due to the common and standard natural delay in the school's timing of payments from the state.
The other thing I think it is important for this board to consider
is whether or not it is reasonable to hold a school accountable, either Avanc or any petitioner, for this commonly used practice if they've never been either required or even recommended to curb its use.
Thank you.
Good morning members of the School Board of Education.
My name is Hector Perez-Pacheco.
I am with the Perez-Pacheco Consulting Group.
We have developed and dedicated our life to assist organizations like Avanza to reach their goals in terms of enrollment, in terms of outreach.
We have implemented a successful community grassroots campaign to reach out to numerous families within the community and successfully were able to achieve receiving over 150 enrollment interest forms in support of coming to Academic Avance.
We urge you please to support the renewal of Avance.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We've supported this school for a very long time and believe they do a very good work and a heavy lift and with a population that has a lot of needs that often otherwise aren't well served.
We think that the school's financial status is markedly improved and that the borrowing practices are extremely common within the charter sector.
Unfortunately, charter schools don't have access to the kinds of capital markets that traditional public agencies do, and so sales of receivables are both necessary and frequent.
We think that the school has more than met the standards of renewal here, both under the comparison methodology, but more important,
The law says that you shall consider growth and academic achievement as the primary factor.
And that should be dominating the discussion here, and we're kind of getting off track with some of these fraught comparisons.
But under either methodology, I think they've more than met it and more than exceeded it, and hope that you will vote favorably on the renewal.
Thank you.
Hi good morning my name is Esmeralda Balvaneda and I'm an alum from Avance.
I graduated back in 2016.
So just a little background.
I grew up in Highland Park and Highland Park is well known for being surrounded by drugs, gangs and most importantly violence.
The establishment of Avance gave students including myself an option other than the streets and prison.
Because of Avance I was able to establish intimate relationships with my teachers that I wouldn't have been able to do in larger schools.
And because of that, I was able to graduate in the 90th percentile of my class.
And even after I graduated, Advancet still continued to support me.
And they helped me get into a four-year private liberal arts school in Oakland, California, Mills College.
Their continuous support got me and my sister through our first years of college.
And it's because of them that I can probably say that I'll be the first person in my family to graduate in May with the bachelor's in legal studies Which would have not been possible without advances help and the support that they gave me I am forever I am forever grateful and I appreciate everything they've done and I just hope that they can get their charter renewals that they continue so they can continue to give opportunities to other first and low-income students like they did to me.
Thank you
Good morning.
My name is Milagros Vizcano.
I am a California Green Building Inspector and a Greenpoint Raider.
I'm currently rebuilding the homes that were lost in the California fires.
I'm the fifth of six children in my family, born in a single-parent household.
I'm the third in my family to graduate from high school and receive a diploma, and the second to go on to a four-year university.
I'm the first to actually begin saving for retirement.
I'm 23.
I was a homeless teenager with a short temper and an even shorter attention span.
Where other schools would have turned me away, Academia Avance listened to me and they provided guidance.
They taught me more than the scientific method, the square root of I, and the Pythagorean theorem.
Every morning begins with a question, what are you doing to help?
Which I don't think I've ever heard in any other school.
Academia Avance demands more of its students than just perfect attendance and 80% or higher on tests and exams and a tucked in polo t-shirt.
Academia Advance has taught me to think long term and that no matter my gender, my skin color, or my socioeconomic class, my future is brighter than my past.
There is no doubt in my mind that Academia Advance is an institution worth renewing.
And I'm thankful to have attended an institution that saw past my immature eye rolls and repeated tardiness.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Jose Chitala, Academia Avanza class of 2015 and recent alum of the University of California, Berkeley.
I'm here in support of Academia Avanza because I can certify firsthand that having this school in my home community has been invaluable in directing young people such as myself towards greater opportunities, namely college.
When I enrolled into Avanza, I was in ninth grade.
My academic record leading up to ninth grade was very sound, but I was missing something equally valuable, a life plan.
Growing up, I lacked the social capital to construct a life path that included college and professional opportunities.
But Academia Avance, a school located five blocks away from my home, offered a unique program that helped close the opportunity gap for me through frequent college trips, two professional internships, and step-by-step college application guidance, and lifelong mentors.
It is no accident that Academia Avanza demonstrates outstanding high school graduation and college attainment rates every year.
Rather, it is the product of a supportive and encouraging school culture that reflects the fulfillment of our school's mission.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Manny Gallardo, I'm an English teacher at Academia Valencia High School, and I'm here to summarize the statements that were written by my students who are learning in the basement of a historical edifice in Highland Park, a place where police do foot patrols after dark, but only on the boulevards.
The avenues don't get the same respite.
Coincidentally, those are the streets where our students reside.
But in spite of the reality that seems overlooked, they come to our school and open their books.
Five years is what it took to build this environment of respect.
I met them in seventh grade.
It's been a long trek.
But we're one year short of arriving at our destination.
If you were to ask them about it, they'd answer without hesitation.
Being college students is their aspiration.
Providing for their family is their motivation.
400 alumni is their inspiration, so I'm left pondering one question.
What can I do to show you our school's worth?
I can't do it with numbers, but I can think of one word, family.
Thank you.
Good morning board members, Ramel Antoine for the California Charter Schools Association urging your approval of Academia Advance's renewal.
They say that it takes a village to raise a child and I can easily say that for the past 15 years Academia Advance has been putting together that village that has been wrapping around these students in this community as you've heard from some of the students today and at the ACC has some moving testimony from parents who've been impacted by ICE.
It's been important to know that school is not just about academics, but it's about the social safety that is available in the community.
It's clear that Academia Advance on the dashboard does not look that great, but we know that there are other alternative measures that the school has put forward in as many ways possible to show that they have been performing at least as well as the schools that students would otherwise attend.
It's really clear that we need to make sure that we're comparing the school with the schools that are demographically similar and not the MAGNA programs in the community.
Those schools can select students out.
These students would not be going there.
It's important that we take into consideration the full context of the school and know that it's a cornerstone of the community.
I urge your approval.
Thank you.
It's my understanding we have a video with this, Tom.
I have three public commenters here via little one-minute smartphone movies.
The first two are in English, the last ones in Spanish, and we have a translator back here who will help us out.
Bear with us as we can make this up as we go along here.
Let's see where we're at.
It sure is.
Here's the first one.
Hi, my name is Angela Vizcaya.
I'm the Director of Student Support Services, and on behalf of the students in special education, their parents, and my special education team, which includes counselors and behavior interventionists, I would like to ask that you renew our charter.
Here's a message from one of our RSP teachers.
She states that to please allow us to continue providing the resources and education needed to empower our students and build a better community for all.
My intern states that Avanza's tight-knit community atmosphere allows our students in special education and all of our students to be supported at Avanza where they could be overlooked at a bigger district school.
So, thank you and I hope that you would consider us for renewal.
Okay, there's the first one.
Hello everybody, thank you for coming out today.
I want to start by saying that Avanza deserves to stay and continue to guide, nurture, and save our lives.
I want to start by saying that Avanza has been my home for the past five years and it has been a blast.
During the years I have been here, I went through the stages of happiness, loneliness, and most of all, comfort.
Knowing that when I leave this place, I will be in a four-year university, knowing that my future is planned, not having to be found.
The unconditional support that Lansing family has shown is astonishing.
Although many people say that our test scores aren't there, we still stand here with all the support of our community and proving every single person wrong.
This will all be thanks to our phenomenal teaching staff.
Without them, we wouldn't know the things we know today.
And no one, absolutely no one could take that away from us.
You might be able to take our school, but it's culture and bond that will stand forever.
Avante isn't just a school for us kids.
It's a sanctuary.
It's a quiet place to do homework.
It's a resource to the community.
But lastly, it's a place where we can call home.
Thank you.
OK.
And now, here we go.
I don't know how this is going to work here.
Hola.
Mi nombre es Romulo Abelica.
Hello.
My name is Romulo America.
I've known Avance for 30 years now.
I think it's very unfair what you want to do.
Closing the school will not be a solution.
Please don't cut the pathway for the kids that already have a way to go forward.
So please be conscious.
Instead of closing schools, we need to open new schools.
So students have more space, more possibilities, more possibilities.
Please give us a chance to show that this school is a very good school.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Seeing no other public comment, we will now close the public hearing for this item at 9 48 a.m.
and commence with board discussion and action.
Oh all right we will reopen public comment.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Good morning.
My name is Dora Arias.
I've been a member of this school for 30 years.
I've been a member of the Parent Teacher Association.
I was here five years ago with two of my kids.
I have two kids that have graduated from Academia Avance.
One of my kids wanted to sell things on the streets.
That was his purpose in life.
He didn't have any vision of what he wanted to do.
But thanks to all the help he received in Academia Avance, he's now doing studies now.
I'm here to support the school and asking you for your support too.
Because I know for sure that in another school they would not have received the support they received from Academia Avance.
I'm asking your support because our community needs schools like Academia Avance.
We need more younger, empowered kids so they have the motivation to go ahead to college.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, board.
My name is Juan Gallegos.
Alexander is a student at Advance.
And I just think it's unfair that LAUSD keeps comparing our school with magnet schools.
And I'm in a very unique position.
I have a son in a magnet school, and it took us over two years just to get him in there.
All of our students from others are not going to go into a magnet program.
They're going to go into a general school that's overpopulated, lower graduation rates, lower college acceptance rates, and it's just unfair.
My son is excelling in advance.
His grades are off the chart at this point.
He was in a public school.
He was below grade level just about in every subject.
His grades have steadily climbed in the past three years.
and it'd be a shame if Advance were to close.
My son is amongst his peers and he's doing such a great job and we're so proud of him that we would hate to see his opportunity be squandered.
Thank you.
Is there any other public comment?
All right, seeing no more public comment, I will close the public hearing for this item at 9.50 a.m.
and commence with board discussion and action.
First, I want to ask Sue Burr as our state board liaison if she has any initial comments, then we'll ask board members if they have any clarifying questions or comments as part of our board discussion.
I actually just wondered if  there were a few pages in the Academia Avanse PowerPoint that I thought were particularly relevant, and I thought maybe we were going to have a video on this, but I just wanted to call people's attention to the special education services, the percent of students with an IEP.
and their graduation rate and college attainment rate for students with disabilities.
And then, excuse me, I have allergies, I promise, not.
I'm far away from everybody.
The focus on mental wellness and then the life preparation program, which are their internships that they provide in grade 12.
And just to say that obviously we are operating under very different circumstances than normal, but at the ACCS meeting we saw many students and I really appreciate the alumni who were able to come and talk.
and we're not able to see the students here today, but it's very clear that this school provides an unbelievably nurturing and supportive environment for students who have traditionally not been well served.
I think you heard that, I think the individual who spoke about family and you see family on their t-shirts is very
compelling and that's certainly what we heard at ACCS.
So I want to just stop there and say that I'll just preview that I hope we can find a way to yes on the school.
I think it's a school that deserves to continue to operate.
It's been in existence for 15 years as you've heard and
I think the school itself acknowledges that it has areas for growth.
I think there are some ways to get there that we could talk about through conditions.
But I'll just preview that for you and then I'm happy to have other board members ask questions or make comments.
Yes, so I just have some areas for clarification.
I just want to say I appreciate all the People who came from the school and the community to testify.
I really appreciate Hearing from you on the specifics There were some areas that I think initially were presented that we saw some alternative data on so I think maybe it's best Stephanie if you first let me just say there were some questions about the financing and the receivables and
And what I heard, so I'm just kind of collecting the information, was that one of the situations was caused by a criteria for our renewal that they, if you could clarify that, and then also that is this a common practice, the selling of receivables, because that's what we heard from some of the testimony, and I know one of the financial status was one of the areas that was of concern.
That's one of my first questions.
So yes, charters do sell receivables.
It is a common practice.
We would hope that after being open for 15 years that they would have a better fiscal structure so that they wouldn't have to do that.
And you do see a lot of new schools do that.
And it's understandable because as we said,
Their state revenue comes in at times that are not always the same as their schedule.
But you would think after 15 years of doing that, they would have a fiscal policy in place that would not have them rely on something that's as unstable as selling receivables.
I wasn't here last time so Carrie Lopes who is in our division can answer the other question.
The issue of the criteria under renewal with the property issue, could you clarify that?
Yeah, I'll do my best to clarify that.
So in 2015 when the board originally approved
Vonsay's renewal in September of 2015, there was a lot of discussion at the board meeting about this property called City Terrace, this limited liability company property that Vonsay had like a 49% interest in.
And so I think there were some concerns that there was some conflict of interest that was going on between Avance's organization and this property.
So part of the condition was that Avance was supposed to kind of disentangle themselves from this property and we were giving him time to do that and then to let CDE know when that had happened.
In terms of a timeline, Avanze did own about 49% interest in the property.
In 2017-2018, Avanze disposed all remaining interest and returned all the rights back as part of a debt forgiveness agreement that they had made.
And then in 1819, the balance of the $196,000 note was paid off to the city terrorist.
It was all paid off.
And then right now, Avanze no longer owns any interest or any part of that property at all.
So us asking for the condition of him to pay off the property
cause some um you know hardship on the budget because the priority was for him to pay off the property.
Okay I really appreciate the clarification.
So my next area question um and comment is about the academic issue so I appreciate um the I understand I'm from the LA County area and I understand the Huntington Park community and I know actually we have quite a few charters in the area provided a variety of opportunities for students in Huntington Park
that have been very positive.
I have not been on this campus, but I do know and understand the need in that community.
What I heard was issues of high college going rate and high college attainment and entrance into four-year colleges
not eligible for differentiated assistance, but some concerns in English language arts and math, and some issues around what we originally compared the data to and what are like schools versus not.
So I just want to reaffirm, so where are we, because that is one of our criteria that we look at is sort of what are the opportunities for students in like comparable sites in the community, comparable.
So could you just clarify, Stephanie,
Where we are on that?
I'd like to make one clarification.
We did go back to investigate and ask the district about those magnet programs in those schools that we originally used for comparison and actually are that Avonza used in pulling out the magnet scores.
So I just want to be clear that they're not magnets
schools, there are schools that have magnet programs within them, so these kids actually would or could attend those schools if they'd want to.
They don't have to be in the magnet program to attend those schools.
So I just want to be clear because it was starting to sound like the whole school was a magnet and kids couldn't get into the school at all and that's actually not the case.
I wanted to be clear about that.
When we look at the renewal, we did acknowledge that they have made some growth in their ELA and that is great.
They also said that they needed to work on math, but in their math scores,
through from grade six to grade eleven uh... have been very very poor uh... even when you even when you take out the magnet school scores which l a u s e allows you to do in their open portal uh... they're still very very poor and and lower than almost all the schools in in that in their comparable school area uh... one of the things that
You know, we did, so we do a de novo review.
We don't depend on LAUSD's review of the school.
We do a de novo review here at the department and with the board.
And when Avanze sent in a new group of data for us to look at and for you to look at, one of the issues, and we did, we were thoughtful and we did take a look at
at the beta they brought in.
One of the problems was we weren't able to really dig down into the data because the numbers of students that they used for comparison didn't change when they were comparing different grade levels.
So I know that sounds confusing, but for instance, they had a total student group of 391 kids.
Then they took out some of the magnet scores and they compared their 391 kids in their 7 to 12 program.
And then when they compared to the 9-12 schools, they still used 391 kids.
So that made it hard for us to figure out how they did their numbers, because they didn't change their total enrollment that they were comparing.
So did you still feel like when you took out the magnet, apparently you were able to do that?
Yes.
Because they talked about
59% better than comparable high schools, 69% better than comparable middle schools.
And I know schools in that area struggle economically in comparison to some other schools.
I'm just wondering if you feel like their data, the revisit of the data was accurate in that their kids are doing as well or better than the comparable schools.
And again, I will say, for instance, they had a chart in their group, in their thing called the CASP High School Comparisons, the 54 non-magnet comparisons, and they said Avances equal 59% better than what they're doing.
But I wasn't sure, we weren't sure, we went back to look at the data.
how accurate it was because there are 21 schools on the chart, not 54, and 12 of them have better SBAC scores.
So the numbers that they use really threw us off because they didn't seem that they were
right numbers and we weren't sure where they got those numbers from because we looked in the SBAC data, the numbers didn't compute.
They weren't the same.
And maybe they have a different way of explaining it or can explain why those numbers didn't compute with us.
And Stephanie, do you believe they are not eligible for differentiated assistance as accurate?
Yes.
And we do have someone from AMARD here.
He was.
Oh, there's Cindy right there.
Cindy's here.
If you wanted, if you want, maybe some clarification around why.
These are the areas that I have concerns about.
So we'll see if there's some other clarifying questions.
Do you want to have a clarification right now about the differentiated assistant list and why some charters fell off?
Well, if it fell off, I just wanted to make sure that that was accurate.
Yes, it is.
It is.
It is accurate.
the list here.
Member Sun and then who else?
Okay, Pagalanon, anyone over here?
Okay, so Rucker, Sun and Pagalanon in that order.
Okay, so I'm going to begin by saying I actually did have a number of questions for the LAUSD officials and I'm not going to be able to get those questions answered because I am really confused
about the data information.
The questions that you were asked by board member Strauss was helpful, but I want to make sure I understand two points.
First of all, concerning the comparison to other schools in the district,
I'm confused about how this list of schools was created.
So there's, there seems to be a difference in the schools that LAUSD, there seems to be confusion about the schools that LAUSD chose to do their comparisons with.
So I want to ask you, when the department did their review, did you look at the same schools that LAUSD used?
Was there, or did you create
a separate list and is there any overlap between the list of schools you used and the list of schools that LAUSD prepared in their presentation for why the appeal was denied?
Yes, there is some overlap.
We pick our own schools and generally we do it by
I don't know the methodology that LA Unified used to pick their schools.
But there was definitely some overlap.
Okay, so the reason why I was asking that is I was trying to understand what the comparisons were and whether or not, because I also was confused by the assertion made by the charter about how they compare to the schools that they were actually being compared to.
So I also don't understand how they seem to believe, their data seems to show that they are actually doing better than the schools that LEOSD compared them to.
Can you review again what your findings were in comparing the schools that you looked at?
Yes.
Okay.
So the schools that we looked at in terms of ELA and math,
Our findings were that Academia Avanze, and I'm on page three of the item, Academia Avanze did not do as well or better than the schools that we used on our comparison list, which, as I said earlier, are eight schools, with the exception of one middle school.
Is Young Oak a middle, or I can't remember.
with the exception of two middle schools.
But none of the high schools did we find that they were doing better than in ELA and math.
And that is with the increase in schools.
So as I said earlier, we only used four schools in our first comparison with ACCS.
And then we decided to go up that number.
And we went with eight schools, some on their list that they use, Academia Advance.
and it didn't change much.
So we still feel that they're not doing as well or better than the schools that their kids would otherwise attend.
And then as it relates to one of the statements or assertions that I heard from the charter was to be fair, the comparison actually needed to look at the grade span or the students from those schools.
So I heard you explain that when they did that or when they looked at those comparisons, their student group size didn't change.
So with each of the successive schools they looked at, you said the student group size remained constant
at 391, does that mean they were looking at their whole enrollment in the comparisons they made?
That is where our confusion came in.
That is what it seemed like.
They do break it out into middle and high, but they use the same comparison number.
I'm not sure if this is, I'm not, I'm gonna tell you right now, I don't believe I'm asking this question correctly.
So in the grade, how many high school students are we talking about at Avance and how many students fall in the other grade span?
Are you able to tell me that?
Not from the data that they gave us and I don't know that I have that off the top of my head.
No, but Avanti can come up and speak to that as well.
Are you asking just for how many 11th graders that have scores, right?
Sure.
Opposed to all of 9th through grade 12?
Yes.
Okay, yeah.
And they didn't provide that with us.
It looked like they used the whole grade span.
So I... Okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
The moment where we need that set of answers.
Shall we do that now?
Yeah, that's probably it.
I think it would be good to ask not only about the numbers of students in each grade level, but how you did in fact make the comparisons on the pages that are being referenced.
Okay, so let me attempt to reiterate, because I am very confused about this data and about the comparisons.
So let me attempt to reiterate for purposes of clarification what it is I'm seeking.
I want to understand because I heard you clearly when you said you felt the comparisons were unfair, particularly because of the school sites the LAUSD selected with choosing schools that were magnet schools.
You also made the point that the comparisons need to fairly look at grade spans of students.
So I want to begin with the simplest one that will help me understand this best since I can see the information about the high schools.
How many 11th grade students do you have enrolled at your school?
We did it for three years, so it kind of moved, but it's approximately 60.
Sixty so it may be it may have been a little higher one year a little bit lower But for your grade 11 scores, you're saying that you had about 60 students So in the chart that you gave us Can you go through and explain to me for your grade 11 students how they compared with the schools you selected?
Thank you
I want to emphasize that the data that is on the chart for the high school and the middle school is data that is directly exported from the LE Unified's open data dashboard.
There are no changes to those numbers.
The enrollment issue is confusing because they state the total enrollment for that center.
Let me be specific, for that center, not for the school campus.
I think what might help here is a school campus is issued a CDS school code.
by the state.
The magnet centers are subcomponents of that.
So the issue here is that the CASP reporting system provides the scores for the entire CDS code.
And if we look at, for example, Lincoln High School, it's the entire one.
But what the uniqueness and the importance of the Open Data Dashboard from L-Unified is it says, here is the component that is not a magnet,
And it tells you the enrollment for that subcomponent.
And in this case, Lincoln has two magnet schools.
Now, to make sure that you're doing an apples to apples comparison, which is what we are trying to get here, is if you add up the enrollment, the total enrollment for those magnet centers, then it matches.
nearly matches the total enrollment for the CDS school that is reported in the CASP system.
We did that verification.
You do have to look at three things at the same time.
The issue is that the CASP system
only tells you the number of students tested per grade, it doesn't tell you the total enrollment for the school.
In a high school, it doesn't include 9, 10 or 12.
This is where you have to put two things together.
It's not easy.
The important part is that the LE unified system
does have the entire enrollment for the Magnet Center.
That's how we were able to confirm, yeah, this is the correct disaggregation.
So I wanted to point that piece out.
Maybe you have another question.
Can you also clarify for us, since there were a lot of things that were said in the last session, how you represented the enrollment of your schools?
Because that also was brought up.
since we were trying to match what the L-Unified data was saying, apples to apples.
So on that particular chart, it's correct that we're only showing the total enrollment.
And that might have been an important clarification to say that for the high school, it's only 11th grade, which is about 60.
And for the middle school, it's approximately 120, again, with variance across the years.
And in that particular chart, it doesn't point that out.
But I do need to, let me, if I can skip to the grade issue.
So it's important to separate out 11th graders to 11th graders, and here's another challenge.
The CASP system gives you scores for individual grades, but not for combinations of grades, unless it's the entire school.
So for a middle school at LA Unified that's six through eight,
they have their entire score 6, 7, and 8.
But what about for us?
So we were able to take the scores for 6th, 7th, and 8th and match the methodology and get the combined score.
It's an average.
It's a straight average.
So we're using our averaged 6, 7, and 8 score to compare apples to apples to LU Unified's non-magnet middle school scores.
And when you do that,
we look favorable.
So this brought the other question of, how did we get to 69%?
What's actually being counted here?
If you look on that chart,
Whatever is gray is not fair to compare.
So there are eight schools, I think on the high school one, and we have three years that we're looking at.
So eight times three is 24.
That's how we do it.
Oh, I'm sorry, it's eight times six, because there's English language, three, and math, three.
Six times eight, 48.
How many times of those scores, the discrete apples to apples score,
was our score better?
And those are the ones that are coded green.
You count them up and you get the universe of all and our number.
Okay, I appreciate that detailed explanation, but what you just said is not what is shown in this chart.
You said you had 60 students enrolled in grade 11.
This chart says 391.
That is the total enrollment for the school.
You are correct.
But you said grade 11 scores only and the chart says the total enrollment for your grade 11 scores only
in 2019 is 391.
It doesn't say 60.
It says 357, 389, 391.
That's why I'm confused.
I don't know.
You said you disaggregated the scores.
That's not what this chart says.
It was saying they disaggregated the scores also for middle school.
Right.
That's not what this chart shows.
So that's why I'm confused.
What are you looking at, Patricia?
This one.
Yeah.
What does the heading say on it?
It says, of 54 fair non-magnet comparison.
He was just talking about middle school, so I had switched to the middle school page.
Yeah, so even between separating out middle school and high school, you have your 5 through 8 plus grade 11 scores, and then grade 11 scores only.
You didn't separate that out in what you presented in the chart.
That's why I'm a little confused.
So let me ask a different question.
So then when you go to the next set of columns, the ELA scores and the math scores, the ELA and the math scores that you have here, is that only for grade 11?
Or is that the combined scores?
Correct.
It's only for 11.
So that's for the 60 students in grade 11?
Correct.
Okay.
And it was either or.
Do I put another column that has the changing enrollment for the grade or do I put the total enrollment as it's reported in the CASP?
What did you do?
We chose the total enrollment because that's also what's being, but let me make sure it's clear.
Though there's no calculations on the scores relative to enrollment.
That's exactly what's reported.
These are copied straight over So it's the enrollment numbers are strictly for reference.
It doesn't impact the scores, right?
So if I can just be sure that yes, I'm understanding the Second line on this high school page.
Yes reports
the total enrollment of the school, but the scores for the 60 11th grade students, roughly.
I think what you are mentioning is there are two lines for Avanza.
The top one is the scores for the entire grade span, 6 through 11.
That is what the CASP state reporting system puts out.
Our contention is, thank you, but
not much we can do with that, because there's very few schools that are sixth through 11th.
If we want to do a proper comparison, what are the scores only for the 11th graders?
And I see your confusion point here about the enrollment.
Actually, probably that enrollment number should have been on the line above, not in the blue.
I can address that.
But it is approximately 60 across those years.
And those scores in blue are the scores only for the 11th graders, which matches
All the other scores are only for 11th graders, because as we know, the SPAC score is only tested for 11th grade.
And on the following page, you do the same thing for 6th through 8th only, right?
One important caveat there.
Those are the scores as reported in CASP for the entire school, because the school grade span is 6th through 8th.
In our case,
This number does have to be calculated, and it's calculated as an average to get the span from 6, 7, and 8.
And it's a simple calculation that's done from the CASP report.
So only those six numbers in blue for this page, because of the grade span, are calculated.
But it's a very simple average of the 6, 7, and 8 score.
Just so everybody's following, the blue you can see on the color coded, but we have black and white here.
I don't know if it's on your screen.
It's on the screen.
I just want to be sure everybody's following.
So on the screen, you can see the colors he's referring to.
And so the colors here are also showing.
the purple which is the combined CDS coded CASP reported score which has embedded the magnet issues.
This gets to the issue of the list.
On October 15th, the list that LU Unified used was the residential comparisons only.
And the methodology, because it wasn't addressed earlier, but it is in their report, is 10 or more students that attend a school.
So they go back and look at our zip codes and our addresses, geocode, and any school that 10 or more of our students would have attended.
So it's a proxy for proximity is what it is.
That means they're not going to go very far away.
looking at schools.
The problem with that methodology though is, especially if you understand the Highland Park area and Board Member Strauss, if I can politely mention that there's Huntington Park and there's Highland Park.
Thank you, I just hope the transcript, I think that's what you meant.
We are serving the highest need kids in the Highland Park area.
Around us is Eagle Rock, Glass Hill Park, other neighborhoods that it is a different issue.
We mentioned the criticism that they did not include the similar composition schools at LA Unified.
In fact, in their report, they have a table and they have a line that says similar composition and then it is blank and there are no schools in there.
So they only listed
residential schools, of which most of them, or I think all of them, had magnet schools in them.
That was problematic.
But that was LA Unified, that was October.
Let's fast forward to February.
And for the ACCS meeting, the CDE used a different set of schools, but they now included another magnet, Washington Irving from Glassopart, kind of difficult, and they included Eagle Rock High School, also a little bit of a challenge.
That inclusion of at least Eagle Rock got mentioned at the ACCS meeting by one of the commissioners.
And so for the third set, it was not included.
So what is the third set?
Since October, we all unified.
We felt it was important to have the similar composition schools, similar demographic schools.
We did an analysis of all the schools in LA Unified, matching on subgroups, high Latinos index and high socioeconomically disadvantaged students.
And by high, I mean like 90 plus, 95% the way our school is.
And we presented that list to the district.
It was ignored.
And we presented that to the state.
It does not show up in the ACCS analysis.
But it does show up, thankfully, in the SBE analysis.
And so the list that is in front of you for this meeting is the composition of
our suggested similar composition schools, which they included, and the residential schools.
It is a much better list.
So at least we kind of got past that.
But now let's step back to the other problem.
Now that we have identified which schools we're going to look at, if the scores that you're pulling for those schools is coming from the CASP report,
you have magnet data in there, and you have grade span issues in there.
This is why it is important to look for disaggregated data.
Maybe not all districts have it, but LE Unified does.
We only discovered this data set like three weeks ago.
We believe it only kind of came online in the fall.
But our point is, this is an important
differentiation, disaggregation, it is a critique that we have been constant in providing and so we present this and I hope my clarification on the methodology helps.
But my last point is
Now you see the green points do show that we compare favorably in a fair comparison in terms of high schools and middle schools.
And we think it's unfortunate that Dr. Perry at the ACSS meeting made the statement.
He agreed with our logic that grade span and magnets should not be included.
He agreed with the logic.
But he also asserted that their data didn't have that.
As of this week, Dr. Perry now is saying, no, Ricardo, you're right.
And this methodology is the better one.
Can I come back to Member Rucker and ask Member Sun and Member Pagalanan to get their questions in and then thank you for asking the questions that got us to this clarification and then we'll keep plugging away.
Member Sun.
Thank you so much.
I think the questions of my colleagues and Mr. Morales, your explanation was extremely helpful here.
So there's two other pieces helpful in getting to the story behind the numbers.
There's another piece too, and I wonder if Academia Advance has that, around students who have been with the school, because I know that you may have students who come in and out or they come to you extremely
disadvantage you know behind in grade level.
Do you have growth data for the lack of you know better word and this is part Carson back to our conversation yesterday without something statewide you know what are you using to show that?
Let me warn you that this was a significant component of the ACCS meeting in terms of
And I think it's a recognition that at the state level, unfortunately, there is not a CDE agreed kind of growth metric.
Either you go with something that relies on student level aggregation, student level data, which is, you can't compare school to school.
I mean, we can give you our student level information, but we don't have access to other schools.
Or you can go to the grade-to-grade comparison, which we did provide to LUnified in October, and we also provided it to the ACCS.
And we can even provide it today, but I was hesitant, given the following critique.
It's true, those aren't necessarily the same kids.
So if you're saying two years ago here they were sixth grade, here they're eighth grade, maybe those aren't the same kids.
Yes, that's true.
But how else can we do a great comparison?
So to your specific question, I would turn you to the slide that I put up here.
Which is the NWA map data?
Now that's a whole nother criticism.
Not all the schools are using NWA map data.
However, they do have a national norm.
And so,
The brown line on this chart is the national norm.
And this data does bias to the students that stay with us over the course of the years.
And what we clearly see here is, first off, there's no skimming going on here.
If you compare to the national norm, the lower grades, the sixth and eighth graders, have a significant gap.
Over time, and this is four years worth of data for the end of the year, they keep, as an average for the whole grade, the score is moving up, such that by the 11th grade, we're getting to the norm.
That we offer is evidence and that shows that over time, the students that stay with us are growing.
And it also explains the issues about, well,
How are you getting all these kids into college?
Hey, if you're staying with us, and you do our academic program, and you do our life program, you're gonna have a high probability of going to college.
What other explanation can I put in here, though, that's difficult to see, but I think is understandable, especially the comments from Board Member Strauss?
Our community, this is the immigrant community.
And so very highly influx, especially at the high school level, we're getting kids in the 10th, 11th, even seniors.
We have one case of a student came to the 10th grade, had to spend three months in a Houston, some people call them cages, but in a Houston ICE detention center.
So it was gonna take him at least a year just to get past that experience to start to focus.
I'm happy to report
that he's well on his way to graduating and he's well on his way to getting into a college.
We're not turning those kids away.
They are a significant component of, or there's even another way, and I think if you knew who this last speaker was, the gentleman with the Dodgers shirt, that's Romulo Avelica.
His family came in front of this board to speak about the separation for six months, given his ICE detention.
He has two daughters that are in the school right now.
That's a huge disruption, right?
So maybe they were with us since the sixth and seventh grade, but definitely during the eighth and ninth grade, there was some other focus going on there.
I'm happy to report that the eldest is a junior.
She's doing very well on her grades, on track to finishing AG, and she's determined to go to college like her two cousins, one who graduated last year from UC San Diego and has a great mentorship in the medical field,
and her sister, who is now a junior at USC, having completed her internship in Washington with Congressman Jimmy Gomez, and is now working on staff for Ilda Solis.
I think I'm going a bit long there.
My point is, you asked, is there any kind of evidence of growth?
We offer this data set with all those caveats.
We have other data sets that show
that hey, sixth to eighth grade, there's huge gains, more so than the magnet school programs around us.
They're at a higher level, but we're showing the growth, and as the point that Mr. Premax said, it's about the growth that is the emphasis in the renewal criteria.
Thank you.
Can I also now ask about the differentiated assistance and this may be the CSEE?
Yes, I think that's somebody else.
Thank you for that explanation as well.
Good morning.
Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
This was the first year that the Department of Education was required to identify charter schools under the differentiated assistance criteria under LCFF because they had additional years that were required.
When we conducted our
analysis of the data and put out a public file, we had 32 charters on that list.
We were made aware, actually by one of the charters, that we had treated our academic indicator differently in our data processing than we had for districts.
And so what the criteria is is that you treat it as one.
It has to be red or orange on one of the indicators.
And so in going back, reprocessing the data, there were nine schools that fell out as a result.
One of them was the school before you today.
So we have notified all of those schools that the correction of the data and that the error was on the department's part and that they are no longer eligible for different jaded assistance under the criteria that is in law.
So that was just a technical glitch?
Technical glitch.
It was, you know, sometimes we make mistakes.
And when we make mistakes, we own up to it.
So that unfortunately... Can you give me the number again?
How many charter schools originally identified and then how many left after?
Sure.
So there was 32 originally identified and we removed nine.
Okay.
Thank you.
We're at 23.
trying to get into this conversation.
Member Rucker did you want to return to a different question?
I had a different I wanted to speak again to the representative from Avance.
So first of all, I want to thank you for your patience in answering my question to clarify exactly what's represented on your chart.
And so, based on your explanation that the first chart on the CASP high school comparisons and the chart on the flip side of the middle school comparisons, you said that there was a high percentage of your schools
that outperformed the non-magnet schools that are on this chart.
Based on what you explained to me, I then went back through these charts to make sure I understood the comparisons that you cited for the non-magnet schools and I don't find your assertion is accurate.
And I'm just looking at the 2019 ELA scores.
You said that you outperformed the non-magnet schools.
Just for the ELA SBAC scores in 2019, you had, for the grade 11 scores, 36.7.
And I found that for Benjamin Franklin High School, for Edward Roybal Learning Center,
Miguel Contreras Learning Center, for their Social Justice School, the Nava Preparatory School, the Woodrow Wilson Senior High School, they all outperformed your program and that's just the non-magnet programs.
Those are the ones.
No, this says no magnet.
It says next to that, no magnet.
Nava Preparatory Academy is a no-magnet school.
Their SBAC scores were 38.2.
Your scores were 36.7.
So unless you made a mistake in designating Nava College Preparatory as a no-magnet school, I don't think I misread the chart.
So I think there is a problem with the data.
If I'm understanding what you said, we do have a problem with the data, but we also have a problem with understanding
what the actual numbers are that are being reported about your students and just based on the data you turned in, you're not outperforming even the non-magnet schools at the numbers that you asserted.
Maybe this has to do with the black and white versus the color.
Because you have to see that there's green versus gray versus white.
White is where we're not better.
Green is where we are better.
And gray is where it's not fair to compare.
Yeah, I only have black and white.
I only have black and white.
And for Miguel Contreras Learning Center, and you do have that in cut, you have it as a colored box on your screen.
But on my chart, it says in 2019 for ELA, your SBAC scores for grade 11 were 36.7.
And for Miguel Contreras Leadership Community,
It was 46.4 and for the School of Social Justice, 34.4.
That's not a significant difference in...
for 2019.
I'm just looking at the correct year but that example is explaining the the and these are primary centers.
These are not magnet centers and the school of social justice has 34.4 compared to our 36.7.
So that's not a significant difference in 2019 and your scores actually went down in 2017 it was 46.6 and 2019 is 34.4.
That's not trending the correct way.
Despite the fact that you want to tell me that there is a two-point difference between your performance as a school in grade 11 and this school, you are not trending the correct way.
You went from 56.2% down to 36.7%.
That is a 20-point drop.
I understand why you want to say you are outperforming.
It was a 20 point drop over those three years that is being reported.
That is not what you want to be proud of and say we are still outperforming the other magnet school by two points.
Do you see what I am concerned about?
I think you will see there's a trend downward on all of these.
But you're the one who's saying you're outperforming the schools.
I think the measure is equal to or better.
But you're the one who said... Let's sort out two things that you're talking about.
One is you're talking about a trend over time, which we can ask you to talk about.
The other is the comparison for 2019 between and among
Or for any given year between and among school well There's a third point over the three years that are being shown their scores are trending in the wrong direction The first point I was raising was the trend so I just want to ask you to separately respond to the question about the trend and then the Comparisons on a given year so that we can at least keep the issues separate
Obviously, it's a concern for us to address this.
And we wanted to show evidence that in this particular year, and with the guidance from the CDE staff, Mr. Huddleston has been a great support for us to find, hey, how are you addressing these?
How are you reflecting on the data?
And we have evidence that for this year, but obviously that's not being shown in this chart.
We did recognize that downward trend.
There is also the same caveat that I provided before in terms of the growth data.
These are different classes, every year is different, and the test is different.
And if we were out of sequence with the trends for the other schools, then that would require a different explanation.
But for that same school that you point to, board member, they went from 34, but they started also at 46 for the English.
So the trends impact everybody.
And this particular test, though, is equal to, we're not saying we're
were better.
I made absolutely sure that it was an exact match or not.
There are a couple of other places where we are off by one or two in our favor.
Let's just go straight up.
Equal to is green.
As a collection, overall, when you look at all of these comparison points,
With all of those controls that I said that make this fair in terms of grade span and magnet centers, overall, the picture emerges that we're doing pretty good here, right?
It's difficult if we're being compared to magnet schools, but if you're comparing us to the non-magnet schools that have a similar composition like these gold schools, then overall, we're doing okay.
Now, can we do better?
Absolutely, and we want to work with the state to do that.
Right, so this will be the only thing I'll say and I'll be done.
You did say you were doing better.
You did absolutely say you were doing better.
With the explanation you gave me and the time that was taken for the other board members to ask questions, I went back through the chart.
The trend is going the wrong direction and the trend is uneven between English language arts and math.
I agree your grade 11 scores can be different from year to year because it is a different class.
But then if I go back through the students in grades six through eight who are moving in to that grade 11, those scores also don't trend well and the performance is uneven from year to year.
So I understand the point you're trying to make.
You're saying we're doing well, but what you're saying is we're not failing as badly as the schools we want you to compare us to.
That's really not a good way to justify what it is your program is doing and being successful.
I'll just insert one point of clarification.
The term is equal to or better, is that strictly what is in the law?
I just pulled that code out.
It is not so much an assessment.
My point is, given the explanation you gave me to help me understand what this data represents, I don't see where it is equal to or better.
And again, I think your explanation helped me understand better and I don't see where it's equal to or better just based on how and I might and I'm going to admit I might still not quite understand what you're what you're trying to compare in this chart But you're not equal to or better Based on how you explain this chart who it is the students are that are represented in these two charts
Okay, so we've got the data questions.
I just want to summarize what I think I've heard about the data, because there's been these questions.
I think it's important for people to look, because this black and white doesn't help us, just so that we're clear.
You're saying on these charts that
In general, and I can see this is true for the 11th grade comparisons, that almost all the schools show a decline from 2017 to 2018 to 2019.
You're comparing them in any given year to other schools that are non-magnets.
Those in white are doing better than Avanc.
Those in green are doing equivalent or worse.
Those in gray are, in your view, not comparable because they are magnets.
Is that right?
And then the other charts that we looked at a few moments ago, which were map scores, are the same students over time.
9th and 6 7 8 now that may be where we need a little more explanation
It's the same where for that corresponding year.
I mean obviously older students are popping off, newer students are coming in, so it's not an exact cohort analysis.
And it's all of the students in the school that are being measured.
It is for grades 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, and 11.
And this is another significant that this tool lets us do 9th and 10th.
And it's all the students in the school who were there
who were also there a year earlier?
Yes.
So it's the gain that they made from your, time one to time two for all the students in the school, okay.
Just so that people know what we're looking at with the different charts.
Are there any other questions?
Just maybe just maybe a comment, you know, I do agree that the the trending down is concerning but what is More concerning more on a larger policy level is the training down for all of these similar composition schools and while I understand board member Rutgers point
It's amazing to me how charters always shine a light on the system.
So I have actually larger questions now by doing this type of analysis, what is happening with some of our student populations and the performance and these types of schools with certain populations.
So that's just a comment.
Yeah, it's concerning actually statewide.
Whoever made that possible, thank you.
One of the things that we are up to our eyeballs in are the differences between progress data and growth data, which is something we're going to revisit in May when we come back to the growth model.
Because from year to year, one group of 11th graders looks different than another group of 11th graders, and that's what we're currently measuring on the dashboard.
But there may be a different group of 11th graders.
And then the test may be different as well.
I mean, that was mentioned.
And when you see those kinds of things, the same thing happened on the NAEP this year.
The whole country went down in reading on the NAEP, and it caused many people to say, what happened with the test?
Maybe the test was incomparable to the test the previous year.
So you don't know how to sort that out when you see those general trends downward.
That's a whole nother psychometric issue, right?
But this chart is looking at the growth of kids who are there at time one and time two and what happened to them.
This other chart is looking at kids in different cohorts coming into the same grade level.
So they're gonna tell a different story.
I just wanted to be sure that we were...
clear about what story, which data we're telling us.
And I think the argument for a growth metric that we have been struggling with and will struggle with some more is that when you're measuring a school and its contribution to student learning, you do care about where that student was at an earlier time versus where that student ends up, which is just a different metric than the cohort metric.
Okay, member Navo, and then I'm going to try to move us towards some kind of a motion and a process, but no, you go right ahead.
I apologize for leaving and I may have missed the questions that I'm going to ask.
I have two questions for you, and I think that
I watched the ACC, the Charter Advisory Commission meeting, and I heard a lot of talk about enrollment.
I heard a lot of talk about funding as well.
So my questions are this.
There's a trend here.
In 2005, you were authorized by LAUSD, and then they requested a non-renewal.
Then LA County Office of Ed authorizes you in 2010 and requests a non-renewal.
The state board then authorizes you in 2015 and then requests a non-renewal today.
The staff.
There's a trend and I'm struggling to find out what you can do to change this trend.
If we were to, you know, recommend some type of
conditions, we're bucking the system.
The system is telling us, this is not working.
You're dealing in year 15 with year one financial issues.
If I understand the receivables correctly, you're selling ADA basically to pay.
You're banking on ADA.
OK.
So my issue is enrollment.
I did not hear about the 100 new students in the charter school meeting.
I'm interested in where those came from, because you had articulated in that meeting enrollment was declining in your area.
Obviously, it was a tough area, and declining all around.
So between the charter school meeting and today, there's two binders full of 100 new students.
So that would be my first question.
And the second one is about funding.
Let me see if I can.
How are you going to make the bottom line 15 years into this thing now?
And it goes into enrollment.
For the first three years of this current charter, we stayed constant at 390.
So the issue is, in this particular year, and there are two parts to that, why was there a particular drop for this particular year?
One is, I think, the cloud of renewal.
We had hoped to be approved by October.
That cloud is, and I think we're gonna, I will get to how I think we've addressed that.
The second one is just the reality of this presidency and the impact to the immigrant families of which is a huge component of our families and the gentrification which is mentioned by Assemblymember Wendy Carrillo.
has hit very, very hard in this particular year where families are leaving.
So this has been a challenge.
How have we addressed that challenge?
Where did all of these interests come from?
We tried a different strategy this year and worked with a professional recruiting group, who you heard from, Mr. Pacheco.
But the difference was in pairing off the professionals with our parents and our students.
And that kind of pairing we had not done before.
Why didn't you try this before?
Well, we did now.
And February is an important month.
People in December and January are still kind of focused elsewhere.
February is when you can really attract, in our neighborhood, attention for our school.
And so we were at the right time with the right strategy, and we had a huge interest that we were able to attract.
And I think it's demonstrated.
So the point is that the budget at 350
for all five years is recognizing we're still going to have to deal with the demographic and economic pressures on our community.
But we believe we can attract at that level.
And the fact that we were able to do that in these last six weeks is evidence of that.
We didn't get 1,000 interest.
That would have been like, wait, where's that coming from?
And the actual number is 150 new student attraction.
That puts us in a good sweet spot in terms of our budget.
So now let me get to this story.
There's actually a longer story.
El Unified gave us a three-year charter, and there was a direct attack on the school in the third year, which we backed it away.
Then they gave us a one-year extension, then they gave us a one-year extension.
So that put us under a huge cloud in that whole first five-year period.
And to be specific, the fifth year under El Unified, we had to take them to court in order to act appropriately on our renewal consideration because they were running out the clock.
And the judge agreed, and the court, the judicial action worked in our favor.
We went to the county, and we won at the county level.
Fast forward, and again, where it's important, it was a no action vote at the county.
It was a 3-3.
They didn't decline us.
They didn't renew us.
So that kind of leads, hey, maybe there's some other political pressures happening here.
Fast forward another five years.
And here's a very simple number.
45 schools were seeking renewal last fall.
44 schools.
got the recommendation from LA Unified.
How can it be?
Even since we're the top three school in terms of getting students to college, how can we be dead last 45th?
Maybe there's something else going on there this last fall with LA Unified.
For a whole nother explanation, I can talk about the SELPA issue and the fact that we were the only school that declared we were not going to join their SELPA.
But that is a whole nother explanation.
But my point is, people keep pointing to, hey, you've been around for 15 years.
How come it's been so hard?
Because it's been so hard where we are.
We're in an area that is very, very hard against charter schools.
I believe, given that this last month was able to show that we can attract students, we have the program that attracts our families, we have what these families want in terms of getting their kids to college, and so we have a square budget in terms of we're not trying to over enroll.
Let me put a footnote there.
How come you claim 600 students
That was the claim from 2015, when we first submitted our charter to the county, because we were going to construct a new building and gain that facility.
Now, because that construction fell through, and that was the partnership with City Terrace LLC, it was a partnership to build a new school.
When the city was going to decline that project, then we got out of that project.
But we had presented to the county, we believe we're gonna have this capacity.
In the current charter that we're finishing with the state, we didn't include that big number.
And so I think that's looking way, way back.
And this current petition, it has the words from the CDE, has a viable plan going forward.
The short answer is we are attracting those students and those binders are evidence of that.
We are not trying to do an outlandish number and not having a cloud over us and having the enrollment numbers that we have now and having addressed the condition that was put on us where we had to write off $1.6 million, we don't have that this time.
So I believe we are in the right place to deliver and the data that this year is showing, the data that the CDE has been monitoring and helping us with shows that we are going to start on the right foot this time.
Member Byrd, did you, speaking of conditions, did you want to speak to the comment you made earlier about what conditions you would be recommending?
So I'm going to hand these out while I make a couple of comments on that so everybody has a chance to take a look at them.
I just want to start with a couple things.
First of all, I do appreciate the real deep dive into the numbers, but I think that it underscored what I previewed yesterday of how desperately we need a growth model.
And particularly for a school like this one, you've heard lots of the challenges, different grade configurations, six to 12, which is a little bit unusual, and both a population that has been underserved, but is also a challenging population in the sense that it's fairly transitory.
So I think when you look from year to year, it's very hard to tell whether those are the same students that you're seeing each year.
And I appreciate you pointing that out.
The other thing I want to say is that just to refresh people's memory about what the criteria are for our approval is that the primary consideration is supposed to be academic performance.
And we've done a lot of delving into that.
But we are also allowed to, and indeed I think are compelled to look at alternative measures.
And with this school, I want to refresh our memory back to the beginning of Stephanie's presentation.
If you look at her slides, and this is slide number nine on page five.
that the school itself is a college preparatory school with the goal to ensure that all pupils complete A to G requirements, graduate, are equipped to be accepted into colleges and universities, and have the opportunity to develop into active citizens.
And I think if you look at those measures, by those measures, which we spent a little bit of time on, and we spent a whole bunch of time on test scores, which I would suggest maybe we should have flipped it,
They are highly successful, and you heard that from their alums.
So I really want you to hold that in your mind, if you will.
And just a couple of other sort of overarching comments.
As I mentioned, I think, at the beginning, the school has been in operation for 15 years.
It has had rocky relationships.
I agree with you, Matt.
Being a non-LA person, I'll just say from Northern California, the politics in LA look really tough to me.
And they look tough at board levels where they're making decisions, especially about charter schools.
So I'll just put that aside.
They do clearly have a college-going culture.
They place a lot of emphasis on that.
And from what you heard from the alums who were here and a little bit on our video and what we heard over and over again at ACCS, it's very successful with, again, a population who otherwise would not be going to college.
So that's very compelling to me.
And I'll just say, as probably the longest-serving charter person,
going back to 1992, the fact that parents choose to send their children to this school that is a very safe and loving community is the most compelling factor for me.
So with that, I would like to recommend that we approve the renewal of Avance with some conditions.
And I think these conditions, and I have copies that I'd like to make sure that, especially Mr. Morales has and the department staff,
recognize the challenges that they have, and I think the school has recognized these challenges.
The first is that they contract with an independent education services provider to conduct a root cause analysis and develop an academic action plan.
That's focused on identifying and approving the school's math and English performance.
I'm sorry math performance and English learner progress The plan must be adopted by the board of direct the Avon say board of directors and provided to the department by August 1st of 2020 so that addresses the academic issues.
I think they spoke to that they shared an academic plan in their presentation that I think is relatively consistent with this and
Number two that they contract with an independent expert to develop a fiscal action plan to eliminate the need for the selling of receivables and to provide training and assistance to ensure effective internal control procedures As well as effective and reliable operations and financial reporting that plan also must be adopted by the advance a board of directors and provided to the department by October 1 of 2020
Number three, Avance staff will provide quarterly updates to the department regarding development and implementation of these plans.
And number four is if we choose to adopt this proposal that they revise their petition to address the issues identified by the department and attachment one.
And these are kind of the standard ones having to do with governance, conflict of interest, and those kinds of things that are relatively new to the statute that need to be included.
So that's my motion.
I think we do need a second.
I'll second that.
Thank you.
Is there further discussion on the motion?
We have member Pagalanon and member Rucker.
Anybody on this side of the?
I kind of wanted to ask just a little bit more.
I don't think we really talked about the plan necessarily, the academic plan quite enough.
I mean IXL, it's just from my perspective it seems like a lot of separate programs.
I'm not quite understanding exactly the cohesive, I'm not seeing really the cohesive plan and I think that I mean it's good that it's a part of the
conditions, I would just hope that moving forward, that if we're checking on those, that plan, that it's a cohesive plan and not kind of a piecemeal plan to help students.
And are you wanting to hear more from the school about what they're doing?
Is that what you were referring to?
Can I just clarify?
Like, will the conditions continuously check up on that and make sure that they're actually working?
Because it just...
So that's the intent, and I appreciate you asking the question, Brenna, that by contracting with an independent provider, too, and we give an example such as WestEd, but it could be any provider.
The idea is a root cause analysis is looking across the system.
It's what we heard about yesterday when we heard about the system of support to make sure all of the pieces are fitting, that it's not, to your point, just we're kind of throwing stuff against the wall to see what sticks.
So the intent here is to have a coach, if you will, right alongside the school that can help them develop the plan and make sure it's implemented consistently.
Is that responsive to your question?
Okay, Member Rucker?
Okay, so I want to begin by saying this school was
mistakenly referred by the department for differentiated assistance.
If they had remained on the list for differentiated assistance, what you wrote in condition one would be the work that they would be required to do if they were in differentiated assistance.
And probably condition two might also occur if they were in differentiated assistance.
And so the point that board member novel makes in their relationship with LAUSD and I agree with you that while the politics of LAUSD's school board and in the community itself are difficult.
The fact is LAUSD, the school board and the community has been very supportive of charters.
It has been very supportive of this charter in approving it initially and with what he explained extending and extending their charter until they got to the point where they denied it and then it was appealed up to the county who approved it and then chose to deny it and it's come up here.
They had the opportunity with each of those denials to learn something from each of those agencies that chose to deny and take a look at their program and do the root cause analysis that should have helped arrest some of the decline
that is evident in their program.
And yes, to Board Member Sun's point, all the schools are declining, but all the schools didn't show a 20 point drop in English language arts, which is the state's best performing subject right now, as compared to them.
The other schools had a 5 or 10 point drop.
not a 20 point drop in their performance.
I don't see where between the time they were working as an approved charter for LASD or during the time when they were working for an approved charter by the county that they did any kind of root cause analysis to figure out what was going on and to rest the evident decline
in their programs.
So, I'm concerned that these conditions give to this charter a preferential treatment to be treated like a school that's in differentiated assistance and they're not.
So, I'm concerned about these two conditions.
Judy Size, I'd like to clarify.
I don't think these are conditions that would be part of differentiated assistance.
Doing the root cause analysis is not something they would be asked to do?
That's comprehensive support.
Okay.
And certainly not the fiscal, I don't believe, either.
Thanks for clarifying that.
Any further discussion?
Again, when we start looking at these numbers, when you talk about the percentages going down, percentages sway quite more for smaller schools as well.
So you have to know what the end for that 11th grade class is to see what that swing in percentage is.
So that's yet another nuance to look at when we're looking at these numbers.
I just would, on this numbers question, I think for me, the growth measures are much more persuasive because it says what the school contributed to the kids who were there, right?
And we know that these are kids who are in and out for a variety of reasons that are reasons we're all concerned about in that population.
So, I think we've got all the data on the table.
I hope we all understand the data as well as we can.
I'm in this context.
We've got a motion.
We've got a second Okay, sue under these they the school would have to pay pay for both of these Okay, and if the board doesn't approve their board is it their board does not approve then they would
So can we remove must be adopted?
In other words, we're telling them you have to do it.
This leads me to believe they could say we can't afford it.
Judy Size, I think the intent with that was to make sure that the board was also part of the plan and not just staff, right?
But if the board doesn't adopt the plan or at some point the school does not meet some of these conditions like any other one of our charter schools, we would send them a letter of concern, you know, and amp that up, you know, and ultimately revocation.
I guess the language is concerning to me because it says the plan must be adopted by them.
I'm fearful that, I don't know that board.
I know the financial situation is tough.
What if they say no?
Then they'd be in violation.
Can we put in this recommendation, they're made aware.
I think we wanted it to be adopted at the governing board.
Another issue would be to involve the community at a publicly noticed meeting.
If you guys want to change it, of course, that's at your discretion.
I'm just trying to think of the intent was that the board and the leadership team are working together.
I like the recommendations.
I don't like the portion of the recommendation.
We're depending on Avanci's board to help us do this.
Let me just describe it a little bit different than Judy did.
It's to ensure that their governance structure, their board of directors buys into this and gives direction to their leadership that this is what you have to do.
It's not that... And that is all as a condition of approval.
It starts out by saying as a condition of approval.
So if the plan is not adopted by the board of directors and provided to CDE by August 1st, 2020, there is no approval.
Does that help?
Judy, you can clarify or Carolyn.
This is similar to what we did a couple of years ago.
I'm blanking on which year.
I believe we did this with Hitech Hive.
The issues we discussed, and we sort of mirrored it on that, was one we wanted, I think Member Byrd talked about, an outside provider so that can come in and help them look at issues a little bit differently, which is consistent with the system of support, as you know, to have sort of an outside provider.
And this is consistent with High Tech High, to have an external provider work with the school leadership and the board so that they're all working in concert to try to improve the school.
If I can add, it's a financial plan.
This board has to adopt it.
The board is ultimately responsible for the finances and the budget, so they can't just let the staff take care of it.
The board needs to be aware.
Yeah, that language at the last threw me off, but I appreciate you pointing out that what I was obviously missing is if they don't do it, it doesn't happen.
All in favor of
okay all in favor of the motion as made say aye aye any opposed any abstentions motion passes
Or maybe seven minutes, we'll come back at 11.15.
It might even be eight minutes, depends.
Okay, I think we're gonna get.
ready to begin.
We'll ask for indulgence from the audience.
The board members have their working lunches have arrived and people will be munching as we move into item 15.
Agenda item 15 is a public hearing regarding the petition for the renewal of a charter school under the oversight of the State Board of Education.
Consideration of one purpose school which was denied by the San Francisco Unified School District.
The CDE proposes to recommend that the State Board holds a public hearing to deny the request to renew OPS.
A transitional kindergarten through grade 5 charter school based on the CDE's findings pursuant to EC section 47605 and California Code of Regulations title 5 section 11967.5.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
Thank you.
So, One Purpose is currently an SB authorized charter school with a term that expires on June 30th.
They did submit their renewal petition to the authority that originally denied the charter, which was San Francisco Unified.
That board denied the petition on by a vote of seven to zero.
And then they came up to the state board.
This was heard at the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
The ACCS moved CDE staff recommendation to deny the petition by a vote of seven to two.
So basis for our recommendation for denial that they are not consistent with sound educational practice and they are unlikely to successfully implement the intended program.
They also, as pretty standard, that they do not provide reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all the required elements.
If you decide to approve this petition, we will need to change some of the necessary language in the petition.
OPS was originally approved by the SBE in 2015.
They are intending to serve 118 students in TK through grade 5.
They currently are co-locating on a Prop 39 agreement with San Francisco Unified's Brett Hart Elementary School.
They have a mission to build a strong foundation for pupils to succeed in school and beyond, thereby escaping the cycle of poverty through solid academic preparation and social emotional support.
We selected five schools serving similar grade spans where pupils would otherwise have attended that are comparable in that they have similar enrollment and similar significant subgroups.
We determined through the CAS data, which is all in your item, that the CAS data demonstrates that OPS does not perform at least equal to the schools where the pupils would otherwise be required to attend.
They do not yet have dashboard colors.
They just started serving grade three a couple of years ago, so they don't have enough years of data to provide a dashboard color for the academic indicators.
They do have them for some of the other indicators.
Here we can see, so we pulled up the CAS data.
You won't see dashboard colors, but the CAS data is here.
15% of their student populations meet or exceed standard in English Language Arts in 2017-18, and then they went down in 2018-19 to where it's just a little over 9%, 9.3% meet or exceed standards for English Language Arts.
Mathematics, as you can see, very low percentages in terms of meeting or exceeding standards.
6.25% in 2017-18, they were able to bring that up to 10%.
in mathematics.
The colors they do have on the dashboard are for the non-academic indicators.
And for 2019, they have a chronic absenteeism rate of 44% and a suspension rate of 5%.
They did improve their suspension rate a little bit, but they did go down in their absentee rate.
English learner progress indicator, they are at a low performance level.
But you can see that they have level four and level three are about 50% or so of their, 52% of their students.
And then here's their progress indicator in terms of how many levels they've increased in their LP.
I pulled out the chronic absenteeism.
We're very concerned about their chronic absenteeism.
As I said, they have increased from 17-18 to 18-19.
And it tends to be... Hold on, I was gonna get to that.
Yeah, so it has increased.
Suspension rates, they have improved from last year, from 2017-18, they went from a red to an orange.
However, they are still red for their African American population for suspension rates and still red for their socioeconomically disadvantaged for suspension rates.
So they're having some issues in terms of suspending students at the school.
We did look at alternative measures that OPS provided.
Some of it, as we've said before, their family engagement indicators, climate, organizational outcomes, rely on assessments and data for which we lack the independent confirmation of for the reliability and fairness.
The OPS review, OPS completed their own review.
2018-19 CAS data wasn't available when they first applied for renewal, but their outcomes are better than the school that they co-locate with, but significantly worse than all the other schools in the area.
And to that point, I think that they're aware that they're not meeting renewal standards, so they did submit to us.
some conditions that they would be willing to follow if the board was wanting to approve them.
We looked at those conditions, and part of those conditions were voluntary closure, which is not something the board can approve or even consider.
So we really didn't take a look at the conditions.
Too deeply because they didn't meet any of the standards of renewal So therefore we didn't condition consider the conditions and also that piece about voluntary closure was not something the board is able to do We would have to revoke if you wanted to close the school San Francisco did their own review and also found that their results were not comparable They are here today.
So they are a district that traveled here.
I'm really happy about that And they will speak to their review when they come up
inability to implement They do have in terms of their projected budget.
So their projected budget includes pupil enrollment for 118 students in 2021 Moving all the way up to 141 they have yet to make any pupil enrollment Goals for their school now, they're under a hundred students right now we have
We have some doubts that they will be able to even make the 118, so their projected budget is viable if they make the 118.
considering the area and considering some of the issues around the school and the fact that they've not been able to even make a hundred students, we have some doubts about that.
They do have money though because a lot of their income outside of the state
allocations that they receive are private donations.
And they're pretty consistent.
We're including them in here.
They've been pretty consistent with their private donations over the years.
There hasn't been a lot of lag time in terms of donations, so we've included those in the budget.
Here's their numbers in terms of what they originally wanted to do when we approved them in 2015.
They were hoping to be up at 312 students this year.
And as I said, they're somewhere in the mid-90s.
Past history under the State Board, they have been issued several letters of concerns for academic and operational noncompliance.
And for one letter of concern was for low ending fund balance and enrollment.
They have, when we issue a letter of concern, we do ask sort of conditions.
We want you to do this, this, and this by this date.
And they have complied with all of our letters of concerns in the past.
We find that they do not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of the following required charter elements, educational program, governance structure, suspension and expulsion procedures, dispute resolution procedures.
In terms of educational program, they were not clear on how they would identify students who are not achieving at or above expected levels, nor how they will respond to the needs of low-achieving and high-achieving pupils.
The petition also does not state that reclassified fluent proficient pupils need to be monitored for four years after reclassification.
Governance structure had some issues in terms of their bylaws and potential conflict of interest.
Those things would need to be fixed if the school moves forward.
Suspension and expulsion procedures.
You cannot involuntarily remove a student for OPS unless the parent or guardian has been provided written notice of intent to remove the people.
They do not state that in their suspension expulsion procedures.
They needed to be more clear that they understood that.
And the petition does not state that when an appeal relating to the placement of the pupil has been requested that the pupil shall remain in the interim alternative educational sending pending the decision of the hearing officer.
So just some issues with the suspension expulsion procedures that we were not clear that they understood what they were supposed to do.
Dispute resolution, this is pretty much the same dispute resolution language we saw for the last charter and that we see for every charter in terms of
recognizing that the State Board can't be pre-bound to contractual obligations and in the matters of dispute, the SB will act in accordance to charter law.
So we are recommending denial of the OPS petition for all of the stated reasons.
And we ask that you deny the charter school on our recommendation.
Thank you.
1132 AM.
First, we'll hear from the petitioners.
The petitioners will have 10 minutes.
Then, we will hear from the district that is opposing the renewal petition.
They will also have a total of 10 minutes.
After the presentations from both sides, there will be an opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each.
So, we'll take the petitioner presentation.
Good morning members of the Board of Education.
My name is Ingrid Mesquita.
I am a board member on One Purpose School.
I'm also the director of the, my day job is actually I'm the director for the San Francisco Office of Early Care and Education.
And I'm here as a board member to introduce you not only to our talented team, but there's also other board members here that are gonna speak to several parts of our presentation.
We have our principal, Annie, who's here, a fellow board member, Joy Jackson, our enrollment and development person, Joy Steinberg, and in the audience, we also have our board chair, Pamela Mann.
And as we speak today about the type of supports that we provide to students at One Purpose, I do want to make one thing in terms of emphasizing is that yes, we do look at academic rigor, but part of the One Purpose school is to also provide
a well-rounded type of programming, which includes the development of children's social-emotional well-being.
And these are part of the wraparound supports that One Purpose School does in a very effective manner.
As part of our, as we have mentioned before, one of the things that we have been focusing on is not only academic, and for which you'll hear a little bit more, the school is situated in the Bayview neighborhood, which is in one of the neighborhoods that is
I would say probably the one of the most highest need neighborhoods of the city of San Francisco.
We're divided between South and East, I mean East and West.
And all the neighborhoods in the Eastern side, very similar to other places in other urban areas, have not only been underserved, but also underfunded chronically for a number of years.
And so what you see is not necessarily a manifestation of something that just happened overnight, but rather of years and years of really overtly racist policies.
And so I hope that you take that in mind as we provide some of this data and also look at what we can do as board members to support the students at one purpose.
So one of the things that we have done in years one and three, aside from the academic piece, is that we have also been under an enormous amount of stress with our founding member, or founding principal, Daniel.
He ended up having to leave the school because of health reasons, and sadly he ended up passing away.
when we replaced them with a principal who ended up also having serious health conditions and she also had to move on.
So there's lots of work that has happened behind the scenes but there's also this other thing that's called human dynamics and relationships that also have an effect on not only on the student body but also on the staff as well.
So, is that one over here?
Okay, all right.
One of the things that we also want to talk to you today is that given all of the work that we have done to stabilize One Purpose is that we also are asking you to give us the adequate time to be able to demonstrate not only our program but also our ability to be able to effectively do interventions that work
So we've made a proposal to you, included in your packets, that we would adhere to voluntary conditions of approval that would allow us two years to meet the indicators aligned to the California School Dashboard.
But we're also amenable to be able to adjust those conditions based on the conversation today.
And we can speak to more about that through either our legal counsel or our board chair.
If we do not meet those benchmarks in the two years that we're asking, as well as this current year, then we will voluntarily close the school, which is something that we do not want to do.
However, this timeline would allow us to share a more complete data story as last year our enrollment was so small in the tested grades and that we did not have the subgroups in order to have those colors on the dashboard.
To be able to talk a bit more about our program approach and also our community, I'm going to hand over the mic to Joy Jackson, another board member.
Thank you.
So as Ingrid alluded to, Bayview has a rich history and does not tolerate savior complexes or charismatic leaders to come in with false promises.
We definitely hold people to what they say.
And so one purpose has really focused on
Addressing the trauma that the community has faced over the years and has proven to be a true community partner Some of the the ways that we've incorporated this partnership is also building connections with other standing strong programs like some of the the preschools and the YMCA and the Boys and Girls Clubs but
In terms of our community, 70% of our kids leave the community for other educational opportunities.
And so our families are looking for and they deserve a viable option in their community.
So here's a quick overview of One Purpose Schools enrollment history.
As you can see in years two and three, we were fully enrolled and had a wait list at the beginning of each year and showed growth in each of those years.
We averaged about 20 students per classroom and had wait lists at the beginning of the year.
Then we found out in year three that our facilities offer for year four did not include any additional classrooms.
So we made the decision to prioritize serving our current students over growth, which meant that we did not offer a transitional kindergarten class in our fourth year.
And we also had to combine our two second grade classes into one third grade class, despite the fact that we had a wait list and could have filled two third grade classrooms.
Additionally, year four's extenuating circumstances that Ingrid discussed are reflected in how we started the current year.
Now moving forward, next year we are projecting an enrollment of 118 students.
And I'm confident that we will reach this number because through a recent survey with our current families, 90% indicated they plan to re-enroll despite all the uncertainty of charter renewal.
We have an additional 56 meaningfully interested students and families in enrolling next school year and anticipate additional applications to come in.
as we get closer to next year.
And additionally, San Francisco Unified School District and its preliminary facilities offer for next year did not challenge our enrollment projections and offered us facilities to accommodate the 118 students.
Can I just say how excited I am that we have 90% of our families interested in re-enrolling considering our year four that was described and the fact that we're in charter renewal currently.
We have really dug deep and pivoted in our vision and mission to make sure that we are meeting the needs of our community.
We were able to reestablish a school-wide culture by hiring a culture and climate coach, focusing on PBIS systems.
We've also hired experienced credentialed staff,
And we are offering a salary 10% over the district average.
And we have opened a wellness center that's supporting our scholars with social emotional needs.
I am proud to share that during the October CDE oversight visit, improvements are observed and noted in regarding to the overall school-wide culture and climate.
We have also focused on robust supports for ELA and math while we have navigated and analyzed our student data.
We are providing six-week intervention cycles, a flood model, and we have a 10 to 1 student ratio.
We've also hired an instructional coach that has really helped us pivot our instruction and take
Our initial focus on project-based learning and teacher-created materials has now shifted and taken the backseat.
So we have adopted new research-based curriculum and really put that in the driver's seat to ensure that our instructional outcomes are where they need to be.
Research-based Common Core Aligned Curriculum is now our floor.
We continue to invest in our teachers by developing their instructional practice because curriculum alone is not enough.
By design, our teacher works calendar includes 20 paid days for professional development and this support along with the ability to provide strategic intensive coaching makes me confident that this development will be fruitful.
One Purpose has also partnered with three partnership schools.
We partner with Seneca Family of Agencies and we have provided three times the number of, we have tripled our number of students and families receiving mental health services.
We also partner with the Boys and Girls Club and nearly 70% of our scholars are accessing free after school care.
And we have partnered with the YMCA where 60% of our scholars are accessing our summer school programs.
We provide a program unlike any other school in the Bayview.
Our Bayview scholars and families need and deserve what we have to offer at One Purpose.
We are here to ask that you use your vote today to ensure our Bayview students and families receive what they deserve by renewing our petition.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Michael Davis.
I'm the director for charter schools for San Francisco Unified School District and County Office of Education.
As you heard from the CD presentation, this charter renewal was presented to the San Bernardino, San Bernardino.
I was in San Bernardino yesterday.
the San Francisco Board of Education for Renewal, the staff reviewed the petition and made the findings that the charter school did not perform as well or better than most of the schools that it compared to demographically and geographically.
And also that the charter school's achievement
progress over the last couple of years was negative and not positive.
We recommended that the board make findings that the charter school did not meet the academic criteria for renewal and that the petitioners were demonstrably unlikely to succeed.
I gave the detailed presentation which
The CDE staff has also presented at the ACCS meeting and I did not bring it back for this meeting.
Just a couple of other things in regard to declining enrollment.
That has been demonstrated in the information provided by the district.
by the charter school and by CDE staff.
There was some discussion in the ACCS about the fact that the district school with which the charter school is located, Brett Hart Elementary School, was experiencing similar declines in enrollment.
That school over the past four years went from 180 down to 164 last year, but in this current year it is back up to 206.
So, it is not experiencing the same decline in enrollment.
As far as the Prop 39 issues, as was stated over the term of the charter, the district has cooperated in meeting the legal requirements under Prop 39 for providing facilities.
That has been difficult because of the co-location with the district school, which also
strongly feels it has a right to grow its program.
The school currently has 10 classrooms in the facility with our school.
Those same 10 classrooms were offered under the preliminary offer for next year.
In the meantime, as was stated, we did agree with the 118.
We know that there are a little under 100 now.
but felt it was reasonable for them to project that they could get to 118 next year.
In the meantime, though, the school has very responsibly approached the Brett Hart School and said we need to plan for the transition and held an enrollment fair on February 26.
That fair was participated in by Brett Hart Elementary and
a couple of other charter schools in the area, and of course, One Purpose.
And at that fair, 18 families actually switched and decided that they wanted to enroll at Brett Hart.
And of course, our Educational Placement Center is willing to make that happen.
So those are the details of what went on.
We will now take public comment at one minute per person.
We do have a number of speakers.
I will call them in groups of five and we ask speakers maintain a six foot perimeter.
Michael Juba, Pamela Mann, Joy Jackson Morgan, Sue Davenport, Trevor Skelton.
We encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Thank you.
Still morning.
Good morning, everybody.
My name is Michael Juba representing California Teachers Association.
I'm going to reiterate probably what was in the presentation a few moments ago at the beginning.
We, as CTA, oppose the renewal for the following reasons.
OPS significantly underperforms as compared to other chosen comparable schools in academic achievement, the chronic absenteeism, suspensions, and the declining ELA and math scores.
The second is they are under-enrolling, which was obvious a few moments ago.
OPS has also shown a consistent history of not serving their students.
In 2019 alone, there were teachers that were not in possession of a valid teacher credential.
as well as EL authorizations.
They lacked an English language advisory committee, as well as school safety and emergency drills, and their pupil CUME folders and IEP files were not properly maintained.
And so for those reasons, we recommend that you deny this petition.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Susan Davenport and I'm the Finance Chair of the Board of Directors of One Purpose School.
One Purpose's funding is uniquely robust and has allowed us to profoundly benefit the students and families in the Bayview.
We engage in extensive local fundraising.
Our Board of Directors is committed to and has been successful in raising up to a million dollars annually to support state funding and provide the wraparound services and level of staffing required
to truly serve the traditionally underserved community of the Bayview.
We view this as an asset and not a liability.
And it's why some of the most traumatized students in the Bayview come and enroll at OP.
They want the services that we can provide.
One Purpose has been extremely successful in its development efforts.
We've been able to mobilize individuals and foundations to invest in the future success of Bayview.
And it's as evidenced by the letters of support we've submitted.
To date, we've raised over $4.4 million from nearly 575 donors.
And last week, our Spring Benefit Dinner raised $340,000.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Trevor Skelton, and I'm a client finance manager at EdTech, One Purpose's back office service provider, supporting the school in its budgeting and financial management.
EdTech has been working with OP since the school's inception, and in that time, the school has achieved a level of financial stability and health that is not common for small charters this young.
The school is a reserve of 18%, well above the 5% minimum as projected to maintain the fund balance percent in its multi-year projection.
This reserve has provided a foundation to mitigate economic uncertainties and support strong monthly cash balances without any receivable sales.
An important lesson in OP's first five years was scale.
One Purpose's new model now assumes a smaller scale than the original petition, with which we are confident in its ability to effectively deliver a quality education while maintaining a sound financial model.
From my experience as a consultant, the school leaders and board of directors are highly engaged and effective partners.
I urge you to vote to approve the renewal of One Purpose School and I look forward to answering any of your questions about the finances or budget.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Pamela Mann, I chair the board of One Purpose School.
I wanted to highlight two things relating to prior comments.
One, first I hope you will give us the opportunity to respond to comments made by SFUSD concerning enrollment and our enrollment fair.
I would hope and expect that you would not hold it against One Purpose School, that we're looking out for both our students and our families and our teachers.
in the context of charter renewal uncertainty.
As far as we are aware, no student has applied for nor submitted an application to Brett Hart to be enrolled.
We would, of course, encourage our students, as we think anyone would, to look into other opportunities, to look out for their best interests, and seek a proper education should one purpose charter renewal petition be denied.
The second thing I just want to emphasize, and I hope you will ask us about this as well, is that in year three, we did undergo tremendous transitions.
As mentioned, our founder and CEO, the visionary of One Purpose, left the school and subsequently passed away.
Our founding principal,
left under ordinary circumstances, but our subsequent principal did not work out and for health reasons had to pass the mantle on to someone else.
Annie Shibley, who you heard speak here today, stepped up ably at the board, jumped in, is a working board, and we have all been more than willing to try and address prior educational inequities in the Bayview.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Jahaziel, and I am a fourth grader at One Purpose.
I started One Purpose in the first grade, and I love it here.
Education is important to me because I know it will lead to a bright future if I choose to do it with One Purpose.
I've learned a lot here at OP, and I owe it all to my teachers.
They dedicate a lot of their time by making sure I get the education I need and preparing me for class projects we do.
I know my teachers care about my future because they spend a lot of time working with me, especially in reading.
I used to have trouble reading and pronouncing words, but now I'm one of the best readers in my class.
Our school is small but has a big heart and that's why I'm here.
To fight for what I believe in.
And I believe in one purpose.
Today has made me appreciate my school and their hard work.
I may be young but I hope my voice counts.
Please keep One Purpose open.
Thank you.
Tough act to follow.
Again, my name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney.
I'm adding my support for One Purpose's renewal appeal.
I did want to draw your attention to an extraordinary step taken by the petitioners, which was to set their own benchmarks for accountability and offering to voluntarily close, to close down the school if they did not meet those benchmarks.
This is truly a remarkable situation.
This is a charter school volunteering to close itself down if it doesn't perform.
This would mean no notice of violation step for the state board, no notice of intent to revoke, no action to revoke.
This kind of offer is very rare statewide.
I can't actually recall an instance where it has been made at the state level.
It speaks to one purpose's seriousness of purpose and their commitment to improvement.
It's also recognition of the gravity of the circumstances that the school finds itself in.
Given this extraordinary measure, we ask that you accept this offer and renew the charter.
I did hear a statement from the CDE that this wasn't possible.
I'm not sure of the legal foundation for that, but this type of agreement has been entered into statewide.
Thank you.
Seeing no other public comment, we will now close the public hearing for the item at 1156 a.m.
and commence with board discussion and action.
First, I'd like to ask Sue Burr as our SBE liaison if she has any initial comments.
Then we'll ask board members if they have clarifying questions or comments as part of our board discussion.
Thank you.
So this is a very tough one for me.
And first, I want to start with this issue about the school itself suggesting conditions.
And maybe, Judy, you might want to respond to this.
There's sort of two things that I'm not quite sure how they arrived at them.
They would be different than our state-adopted criteria, if you will, for movement on dashboard and those kinds of things.
So I don't know if we want to
kind of go down that path.
But beyond that, they're suggesting a time frame that I believe is not consistent with state law, that if we renew a charter, we are stuck with five years.
I'm looking for Judy.
And that our ability to do anything with the charter is restricted to revocation in the event they were not to meet the conditions that they set.
So I just want to clarify that.
I don't, the last speaker said something about this has been done on a statewide level.
I don't know what that means.
I'm not familiar with that, but anyway.
Judy Sias, Chief Counsel.
I'm not aware of
anything statewide either since I've been here, not to say it hasn't been done before that.
I'm not aware of anything, but Sue is correct.
The school does not meet the renewal conditions, which I think they've acknowledged, and what they're basically asking for is an additional two years to try to get there.
They say they'll voluntarily close if they don't get there.
The issue is there's really no way to enforce that.
Should two years from now there be another school leader, another board, or there's some disagreement over the data, the only way we as a board could enforce that would be to go through the revocation process.
Just to clarify that point and so for those of you who are interested in the conditions that they suggested they were in our letters, so you can take a look at those.
I think for me I come down to the sad decision that this school has had five years.
They've struggled for five years.
You've heard a lot about the enrollment and
There are, and Mike did talk about this in more detail at the ACCS, there are a lot of other options actually in this area that are available to students.
So I unfortunately come down on the side of the ACCS recommendation here that we deny the renewal for the school.
Thank you.
So, I think we can now turn to any other board discussion.
Member Rucker?
Member Strauss?
So, I agree there's, whenever charter school appeals get to this level, with each successive meeting and appeal that the school representatives from both sides have, the emotions level up and become more intense.
And the concerns about what is happening at the charter get a laser focus with each successive hearing.
I am sitting here looking at this charter and thinking about the two charters that we are tasked with considering today.
There are some stark differences.
One charter has been in place for 15 years and this one has been having some problems for five years.
What I see is different is this charter does recognize their struggle and is asking the board as part of their appeal for some assistance and seeking to negotiate some conditions to address their concerns.
And we're not doing that with this charter.
We did that with the previous charter and they didn't ask for it.
They didn't even seem to recognize that they were having a problem and that they were struggling.
But we bent over backwards to create a set of conditions for that school.
And I voted for that primarily because the conditions that were established, even though it did treat that charter differently and created a special status for that charter, I believe those conditions will work and ultimately contribute to the success of that school.
So while I generally, as you all know, oppose failing charters, I just can't help but wonder why this dais is not bending over backwards to do the same thing for this school.
We can just go around, yeah.
I don't know if we can return if Sue wants to speak to her analysis.
Brenna?
Do you want to go next?
Okay.
Ching?
I actually just had some specific questions on some of the information that was provided.
One for CDE staff and the other for chronic, for the charter regarding their chronic absenteeism rate and was that the result of all the changes and things like that and how you're tracking that?
Actually, I have another question around the fundraising piece of it.
The CDE question I had was around the oversight visit.
The petitioners seemed to feel that the oversight visit was fairly positive and I was curious what CDE staff saw in the school, what was happening in the school.
So that's for CDE staff.
And then my other two questions was for the party.
So our staff visits the school, obviously, every year.
I have not seen the, we had the consultant here just a minute ago.
But beyond that, for the five years of their existence,
As I mentioned in the presentation, there have been many letters of concern.
Some of those are around teacher credentialing, school safety, people records.
ELD instruction lacking proper designated integrated ELD instruction of pupils.
So we have had many concerns with them.
Our consultants are very good about working with the school to try to support them in meeting our concerns and rectifying any of the deficiencies that they see.
I am sure our consultant was positive because he always is when he goes to the charter schools and works with the staff.
And so if they are making some progress this year, we don't have any of the results yet for what they're doing this year in terms of scores or student scores.
But he very well could have been positive with them in terms of the progress they're making.
I haven't seen any evidence of that, and I don't know he's here.
Carrie, do you have any specific about the actual site visit?
So as required by law, we take our responsibilities very seriously in the oversight unit and we conduct an annual site visit and we have a monitoring instrument that we use and we actually go out there and look to make sure that the
the school is aligned to its petition that is in compliance with the MOU that it has with the State Board of Education and that it is in compliance with the monitoring instrument that we use going out.
In addition to that, we do some classroom observations.
We do talk with stakeholders at the school.
We have a general set of questions and then kind of make a
And then after that, we come back and we have some discussions around it, and then we put together a letter.
And that's what, when you see in the actual item, you can see some of the letters of concerns that we've sent out in the past.
So when we did our site visit in October of 2019, they had met the criteria that we look for when we go out on the site visit, and the letter that was sent out was not a letter of concern, but a letter that they were meeting the requirements and were compliant.
as of October of 2019.
Right, oh, go ahead, I'm sorry.
So that all sounds great, and I think that's absolutely right.
We should be doing that kind of visit.
Does that visit provide any support for the recommendation?
I know that we have specific criteria on the renewal piece of it, but it seems that the visit piece, if you're feeling the school has got a firm grasp now moving forward,
that that would be a part of our review of the school.
We do look at the past operation of the school.
I mean, that's part of one of our criteria for renewal.
And the school has, as you see looking at some of the letters of concern, the school has struggled in the past.
They've had some academic concerns.
They've had some operational concerns.
they've had some concern we've had concerns with them on the implementation of programs we've had concerns with them on just the day-to-day operations of the school so our consultants have worked very hard with this school in order to build that relationship with the leadership of the school to give our recommendations we've been out there more than once we of course do our annual site visit but outside of that we've been down there
many times to provide support and technical assistance and support to the school during the last couple of years.
And I think there's a balance that we have to strike in terms of how much support we give the school and how much they should actually be doing on their own.
And in terms of sort of balancing what
what our thoughts are or what our observations were in October of this past year and whether that outweighs their chronic issues and outweighs their academic achievement levels, which are really low.
And they acknowledge that they're not meeting the criteria set in law for renewal standards.
Yeah, and that's what I was trying to get at.
So the last review, which seems like it's more positive than in the past, was that the person who reviewed felt firm enough, confident enough, that the school was on a positive trajectory?
Or is it okay, but probably feeling that, yeah, based on past trends in history and all that, even though they're doing a little better,
Right.
Not enough.
And I think that, yeah, I think that that is more the case in terms of it's a one look shot in October and like, OK, so you've gotten some things into place, but it doesn't outweigh or doesn't even come up to what we actually need the school to be doing internally.
OK, thank you.
That's that's what I was trying to get at.
And then can I just get the chronic absenteeism from the petitioners?
And then I have a question around the fundraising.
Hi.
So we recognized our chronic absenteeism.
As Ingrid shared before, year four was really, really challenging for us.
At that point, I was the assistant principal.
We had our principal step down.
And as she had mentioned, our founder CEO stepped down for medical reasons and has recently passed away.
And when our new principal had stepped in, and I was the assistant principal at that time, she actually stepped down because of a high-risk pregnancy.
and I stepped into the principal role last year in November.
I've been with One Purpose since we opened, but a lot of that change in leadership, as I'm sure you all know, is really, really complex, which impacted our absenteeism.
So what we're doing this year moving forward is we had meetings with families leading into the year before we even started in regards to absenteeism and helping our families find ways to have their students come to school regularly and on time.
and we've worked with individual families to create specific plans.
We've also worked with our wraparound services team and so partnering with Seneca Family Ed agencies, our clinician, and our mental health counselors to support families attending school.
We're having SARB meetings bi-weekly and continuing to send letters home and hold meetings and ways to support
our families with absenteeism.
We've also created a positive reinforcement system for individual students and school-wide, where students are earning rewards based on attendance as well.
And just to give the board community context, Mike had mentioned Brett Hart also went in a decline too.
Well, we are dealing with some community issues right there.
Most of our students come from a particular housing site, which is Alice Griffith.
which also underwent displacement.
So we lost some families.
As you can see, Brett Hart is gaining some families back because some of them are coming back.
But during that school year, not only did One Purpose go through its transition, but the community went through a very traumatic
transition to where people were displaced and then put into a new system.
If you open up the newspaper today, you could see how that community is still grappling with that transition.
So we as a community partner and trying to be a stabilizer in the community also had to deal with that as well.
So we lost some stuff during the move and it happened in the middle of the school year.
And we have seen more engagement this year than we have, specifically with our school events as well.
And we have, at our most recent parent-teacher conference, 84% of our families attended.
And I can answer the fundraising question.
Okay, yeah, if he could please.
I was curious of the nature and where the fundraising is coming from because your budget is solid because of that fundraising, but you can't rely on it.
And so, and I understand that, you know, you're going to get increase, you have a plan to increase students, all that, but I'm curious where that funding is coming from.
So the private funding that we receive is
a lot of it is raised through connections that our board has.
So we have a very thorough fundraising program that involves reaching out directly to people through direct mail.
We have tours of the school where donors come, see the school, and make donations that way.
We have a spring event.
We had our spring event last week that raised $350,000.
And then we also solicit funds through private foundations as well.
So we have a robust fundraising network.
So we have myself.
We also have worked with a development consultant as well.
And then we have board members working a lot on reaching out to their contacts as well.
And we've really spread out our fundraising.
So we're not solely reliant on one or two large funders.
And if that funding drops out,
then our fundraising budget drops significantly.
On any given year, we have about 300 donors.
So we've spread out the fundraising.
So if a donor, if, say, a foundation changes their priorities and is no longer funding charter schools, for instance, and we're not receiving that funding anymore, we can make up for that in different areas because we have a diverse group of supporters.
So first, I don't want to thank the community and parents that came today and the board.
I mean, I really hear a strong commitment to the Bayview and to continue to provide a nurturing site, even though it's a very small group of students right now.
And I think the structure of the wraparound services and the
coaches and professional development, the thinking around that structure seems solid to me, and the service.
When I look at the chronic absenteeism, which I share with most of us that that's a concern, I also see that Bret Hart was really high on that comparable list too, and that's the community.
So I recognize that all the schools compared have read in their chronic absenteeism, so something that obviously is an area that they're addressing.
It is a small number of kids.
I counted at least three or four changes with the CEO on the several different principles, and we know that stability of leadership makes a really big difference.
I appreciate the stepping up the assistant principal and the work that you are trying to do, but how hard that is when the founder lays the foundation
the mission, everyone comes there and then he gets sick and is lost.
I recognize that that is a predictor for lack of stability and it is too bad for the community and for the kids that were there.
The other comment I wanted to make about
You know, I think we've talked before as a board about sometimes we wish we could give a two-year renewal with conditions and not a five-year and I know that changes but not yet.
And I wish we had a shorter, if we had that as an option, I think that would help because I think the commitment is there.
I appreciate the board, the fundraising is amazing for such a small
population that the community has and I know the Bayview really depends on strong supportive schools for their community.
So those are just sort of the highlights of my comments on my notes that I made.
Yeah, I have a question for Stephanie on the governance structure.
You had mentioned there was a conflict of interest there.
Couldn't you say more about that?
Well, Stephanie, while you're doing that, I have a question.
What I normally see as I read the letters of support is multiple letters of support.
Am I correct in that there's only one letter of support?
All the letters of support that we received are in your mailbox.
That's what we have.
Okay, so it just concerns me that I don't see a letter of support from the California Charter Schools Association.
So I just want to point that out.
I don't see that.
But can I see, you had mentioned conflict of interest, and I just wanted to know a little bit more about that.
some of the governance issues that that came about.
And I'm just so you can follow along if you want to.
I'm on an attachment one on page 25 and 26.
So there were some issues with the fact that in part of their governance structure, there should be a CEO.
They did not have a CEO for a long time.
The principal was being the CEO of the corporation.
And as the board appoints and removes corporate officers, fixes their compensation, it seemed like that could be a potential conflict of interest with the principal actually acting as a CEO in terms of being on the board and also staff of the school.
Also, and then one thing I didn't mention before, and this is something that
is big, you know that now all charter schools are required because of SB 126 to follow all of the Governance and Public Records Act and Political Reform Act and Conflict of Interest Act and they did not have that anywhere in their petition.
So that was under the governance issue was another concern for us.
First, I also want to thank all those that have come before us today, in particular Yahaisu.
Your voice does count, and sometimes adults have to make tough decisions, but know that you're a very smart boy, and thank you for coming, and I'm sure you're going to do great things in life.
I have an observation and then a question.
My observation was also the fundraising and it was very impressive.
But I also wonder how that could be the one consistent thing that didn't suffer when all the transitions were happening with the school, right?
There was leadership transitions, there's low enrollment, at no point was the enrollment targets hit.
but yet there has been consistent fundraising and I am wondering if maybe it would have benefited the school to redirect some of their attention to those areas where you knew you were falling a little short.
My question is about the TK.
And I heard that one year there was no TK enrollment.
And I'm wondering if the original charter school identified TK as one of the grade levels, because I don't believe this school came before us for a material revision.
So I'm wondering if TK was part of the original proposal.
That would be for our charter folks.
That's for CDE.
Was their original proposal, did it include TK?
And I know, I'm sorry, I know you're frustrated.
We'll get a chance to get back to the charter school, but this is for our own people.
Yeah, the original charter that was approved in January of 2015, I believe it was, did include TK.
So not implementing, not recruiting a TK class one year, would that not be a material revision that they would have had to come before the board to not enroll that grade level?
That could be true, yes.
I think the problem that they had ran into is that they were not given a Prop 39 agreement that would allow for an extra classroom for TK.
And I do believe that with the past leadership in the charter schools division allowed them to do that for just the one year.
I know the school is eager to clarify something, so is it okay if they come up and do that clarification?
The CEO position was not filled when our CEO departed the school.
We were in constant conversations with CDE staff about our lack of having a CEO because we understood and could read our bylaws and our charter, which indicated that we had to have a CEO.
The CEO never served on the board of directors.
That was never a part of our bylaws or the charter.
When our principal took over the running of the school, our principal did not become the CEO of One Purpose.
I was.
As board chair, I essentially was in charge of the school.
I don't believe there was a conflict of interest and the board certainly has always maintained the ability, though not the desire, to hire and fire Annie Shiblett.
In terms of fundraising question that you asked about the constancy of our ability to fundraise, the Board is very proud of the fact that we stepped in more than a Board should ever step in with the running of an organization, non-profit or for-profit.
We are very proud that we were able to participate and help the school through the difficult transitions.
That did not preclude us from asking questions and trying to be involved in the program side.
items that have documented the programs and the fundamental steps we have taken to try to turn the program around.
One was not dependent on the other.
There was enough time for both.
Frankly, fundraising was easier than turning the program around.
Just to clarify, is the plan to increase academic achievement just to increase research-based learning?
Was that the only piece that was mentioned?
So we have adopted new curriculum this year that was research-based.
So originally, we were using project-based learning model with research-based curriculum.
And we realized that our students weren't getting as much as they needed with project-based learning.
And so now we're implementing our research-based curriculum that was adopted.
This year, we're in the implementation model.
And then we also have six weeks intervention cycles for ELA and math.
for our scholars who are behind.
And so what we have observed within our six weeks intervention cycle is that our first cycle, which I know this data is kind of irrelevant in the sense of the way that the vote is made, but 100% of our students made progress
at the rate of their peers.
And then within that intervention cycle, 47% of our scholars made three or more levels grow specifically in the area of reading, which is showing that they're making accelerated growth.
And so we are continuing to initiate intervention cycles.
We'll have four this year to continue to show increase in our student achievement.
And so with that, we go through that process.
We also have the coordination of services team, which is similar to an SST model.
However, within that model, we do have our Seneca providers there as well, and so it's really a wraparound support team to ensure that we are moving forward with the correct protocols around special education as well.
Since you're here, I'd like to add a couple more questions if that's okay.
Another area of concern was the rate of suspension, particularly for black students.
It was on the dashboard, even though there's a social-emotional learning component.
I was wondering what's happening with respect to that.
So I really believe in unconditional education.
I'm a former Seneca employee, and I transitioned over to One Purpose.
And so we are doing everything to ensure that our students are not being suspended in their accessing curriculum in school this year.
And so our suspension has definitely decreased.
And we have, with the Wellness Center, we've just observed, in general, a decrease in our discipline data.
At the ACCS meeting we showed a specific slide, I don't have it here today, in regards to our improvement on office discipline referrals and it is reduced tremendously.
I'm pretty sure it was about nine students a day were receiving office discipline referrals in the fall.
of 2018 and then in the fall of 2019 we ended up at around two students a day.
So our entire culture and climate of the school in general has shifted and I think just allowing students opportunity and space in the Wellness Center and also having staff there to provide social emotional learning supports has really really shifted our even the conversations around suspension.
Not so much a question, I think a statement to what Member Rucker said at the get-go that when we are looking at these charters, we really need to look at not one over the other, but do our due diligence in each one of these charters.
I have tried to do that in looking at this.
And I think I'm conflicted on this particular one because I think the mission is strong and there's definitely dedication, commitment on the part of the board and the folks who are involved in the school.
However, I think as Member Navo pointed out, looking beyond the numbers, I need to hear a compelling reason, a really compelling reason when the numbers don't look good as to why you should keep the school open.
And I'm not feeling the sense of the community coming out and supporting the school or if you have so much fundraising and so much support on the
Fundraising side of it.
Why are we not seeing the belief in the mission and the support in letters and other other areas?
So this one I think this is what differs this one for me versus the other.
Seeing none, do I have a motion?
I move the CDE recommendation to deny the renewal of one purpose school.
Is there a second for that motion?
I'll second.
All right we have a motion a second is there any further discussion?
All right all in favor of the motion as stated say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
I think we need to see a count.
So please raise your hand.
All in favor of the motion as stated, please raise your hand.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
And I think that's it, because you don't vote.
Okay.
We have to have a minimum of six, so when it's quiet, we need to be sure.
Thank you very much.
We do appreciate all the people who came out and the work that you've done in that school.
pick up item sixteen general public comment public comment is invited on any matter not included on the printed agenda are there any public comment yes we do have one speaker uh... agustin your jolly how much time do i have one minute okay alright well uh...
Good afternoon, members of the board.
I'm here on behalf of the California Emerging Technology Fund.
That is a statewide nonprofit organization with the mission of closing the digital divide across California.
I am in charge of our school to home initiative, which is a strategic initiative focused on supporting underserved middle schools with the integration of technology so that they could be very purposeful in not only closing the digital divide, but also the achievement gap
We do this by providing a different levels of support, framework of support, consisting of 10 program components, ranging from leadership support, instructional support.
There's a deep parent engagement.
There's also various times to when we bring our partner schools together to share best practices.
This past year, we had a very successful academy.
We're very honored to have
Ms.
Rucker, come and join us.
We had a great conversation.
The schools were energized.
They came out really focused.
We had a good conversation.
I'm here to share our program and hoping that we can start a relationship where we can share our tools and resources.
We're helping the schools.
We're making progress in the school, but we want to explore how we can
collaborate so we can impact the numerous other schools that are struggling academically and being effective in their use of technology.
Thank you very much.
We do have a number of other speakers.
Please state your name and affiliation.
Good afternoon, Dale Marsden, Superintendent of San Bernardino City Unified School Districts.
This will be my last time in this capacity speaking to the State Board of Eds.
It's a pleasure to be here again.
We brought some student board members with you and as you followed our trajectory the last eight years, we've had our students' performance in high school graduation rate was in the low 60s.
We're now over 90% graduation rate, over 50%
career pathways, double the number of students ready for college.
Our pathways are built, I said on the workforce board, are built using predictive analytics and back mapping those to create 50 career pathways and our students are now involved not only in those pathways from elementary to middle to high school but also
continuing on to Generation Go in full paid internships for our students in partnership with the Workforce Development Board.
We've seen incredible outcomes for our students participating in this internship program.
50% of the students are getting employed.
Over 75 to 85% are going on to two and four year college experiences.
We're very excited about the future for them.
We're excited about the student voice component in our school district as you see our students here.
We want to thank Ms.
Ortiz-Licon and Ms.
Sandoval for your support on the State Board of Ed, and such a pleasure to be before you and excited about the opportunities for our students.
I'll let them speak and use the remainder of our time together.
Hi I would just like to speak on behalf of our pathways.
Just last week I was able to visit Cajon high school, Norton elementary school and Curtis middle school just to see what they are working on with our different pathways.
An eye-opener for me was to see the elementary kids, their learning area and
Perimeter they may not use that mathematical lingo, but they are learning that and so I figured that That basis is so extraordinary because in elementary I was not doing that and when they get to middle school in high school it'll be so easy for them to just hop along because they already have that basis of that knowledge and
At Cajon, they have so many pathways from machining to craftsmanship, building boats, racing boats, and it's just crazy how much potential these kids have in that our district is allowing them to unleash that potential and just go and soar with their future careers and find a passion that they love.
Thank you.
My name's Vanessa.
I go to Arroyo Valley High School.
So personally, my high school has, I think, about maybe seven pathways.
There is VAPA Academy, Visual and Performing Arts, CORE Academy, they emphasize helping the environment.
There is business and logistics, there is national security.
I'm in global leadership, so that is basically like 2.0 for AVID.
And so the first two years is you do NYP, so it's just like the honors courses.
And then you get to decide whether you do AP or IB.
And it's been a really good experience for me.
And personally, I have always tried to like
keep it going, and I know there's a lot of students that struggle with their mental health, so I've always advocated a lot for kids to get the help with their mental health so that they can keep on track with all their schoolwork.
Hello, my name is Eric Morales.
I would like to express it is our great pleasure to have had the opportunity to speak before you all today and give you guys our gratitude for having been so supportive of the career pathways and the local control funding formula.
I'd also like to emphasize the importance of programs like Generation Go for the students in our community.
Lastly, I can proudly say on behalf of all the students in San Bernardino City Unified that you guys are doing an exquisite job and thank you guys for having us.
Good afternoon.
How do you follow that, right?
So I'm Ginger Antoveros.
I'm the Executive Director of Community Engagement for San Bernardino City Unified School District.
And I just want to emphasize as well the value of the local control funding formula.
Not only has it made incredible outcomes in our district, you've heard the outcomes from Dr. Marsden, really increasing our graduation rate, doubling our A to G college preparation rate, giving our kids really powerful opportunities to connect with the community.
But it's also served as a catalyst to help our community come together in a program called Uplift San Bernardino, helping us through a collective impact model to really embrace the success that our kids can have locally so that they can stay and be part of transforming a community that right now is living in poverty.
And so we really want to thank you for that investment and that trust in our local leadership and putting the investments where they're needed to change our own communities and the trajectory of our children's lives.
So thank you for the work that you do.
Thank you very much.
Thank you guys for, yeah, I just wanna thank you guys for coming all the way and giving us such an uplifting end to our meeting.
Thank you so much.
So I just have to say, I have seen these pathways and schools in action in San Bernardino.
I've been very fortunate to visit several times, and this is really, truly in action, an amazing turnaround, and I just wanna thank Superintendent Marsden and the team for coming, and what a nice ending to our two-day meeting.
Just thank you for taking the time to come over and talk to us.
I also want to thank you.
There are three board members.
We sit together along with the community college board of directors on the California joint workforce pathways advisory committee.
We have heard from a lot of programs about the work that they are doing and I would be thrilled if we would have an opportunity to hear more about your success and hear more about your pathways program because we're beginning the work now of creating a statewide plan for CTE and I think a lot of what you all have done with your successes would inform that conversation.
So I'm hoping that in some way we'll be able to see you
at a future meeting.
So congratulations first of all, you students represented your schools well and I appreciate getting that A grade.
I also want to say just as it relates to the representative from the California Emerging Technologies Fund, I really would like to encourage board members if you have not had a chance to visit their program or to observe or listen to some of their participating partners.
This is a program that's doing the work that we expect in the LCAP
with creating partnerships, creating true stakeholder engagement, and moving from the school into homes to help engage parents in the support of their children.
So again, this is another program I'm hoping we have the opportunity to hear and learn more about.
I was very excited by the academy I had a chance to participate in and attend, and I hope that's something else we get to learn more about.
So I'm very thankful that the board supported my ability to go to that.
Perfect.
So we want to close the meeting with a little bit more announcement about where the state is on the situation with COVID.
There was just a press conference that the governor oversaw, one part of which does note that notwithstanding any other provision of state or local law,
including the Bagley-Keene or the Brown Act.
A local legislative body or state body is authorized to hold public meetings via teleconferencing and to make public meetings accessible telephonically or otherwise electronically to members of the public.
That means us.
So this may be the last meeting we have in person for a little while.
So we will all give each other very fond elbow bumps as we leave because we may see each other on Zoom next time.
And Lisa Costanza is back with us to give us other updates about the progress that's being made with respect to school issues and closings.
Okay.
I think the only other thing that I would highlight from the governor's press release today is that he did still continue to reiterate how essential schools are and how essential they are in the communities.
And he did say if, a big if, if you are moving forward with a decision to close your school, how he really wanted the focus to be around the guidelines that came out on Saturday from the California Department of Public Health.
And he continues to emphasize that and continues to emphasize the big if and what the implications are to the community.
And that those decisions need to be made with the local public health department.
So I think that's the biggest thing I wanted to emphasize.
He also continued to refer to his guidance that he put out yesterday and exactly with what President Darling-Hammond just mentioned around Bagley-Keene.
So we will continue to work with them and send out email guidances as we can and as we are ready.
The one we're working on now is around distance learning and so we will be continuing to update that and have some information hopefully by tomorrow around that topic.
I know that's a big topic for many school districts, distance learning and independent study options and how to access those.
So that if schools cannot be physically open, they can be virtually open.
Correct.
And we're also talking about how the USDA waiver and providing meals would work along with distance learning and whether that's a pickup location when they come to pick up their meals.
And it may be as simple as having a paper package available to some students who don't have access.
So we're working through different scenarios and we'll have some additional guidance here in the next couple of days.
Thank you.
Stay tuned.
I now adjourn the March 2020 meeting of the State Board, and we will see you some kind of way in May.
Thank you.